and you don't you don't want to spit
that [ __ ] out so that's why those
species do you get in trouble on the
airplane with it if they see them like
sir no tobacco no no one cares because
yeah i don't spit but they'll they'll be
like sure notes i'm like no yeah it's
not like that no it's a little pouch so
so now you do
how many milligrams are you doing right
now this is six milligrams six
milligrams one he's got one one in yeah
now hold on
you're doing 19 milligrams
don't be a pusher you're being a bully
pusher i don't know he's like a guy's
guy i was i was thinking
yeah my boy mike catherwood i'm not even
trying to flex on us right now there's
no flex about doing multiple there is
we're like
we're like a friend yeah
he gets them from sweden and they're 40
milligrams oh no 40. that's this is i
took one that i literally threw up
everywhere is mike doing 40 milligrams
he's a nut he's in the mic now you do
you do three patches i do three six
milligram patches
and i go through a candidate so your
blood pressure is always super high yeah
okay yeah
and then i live my life one quarter mile
at a time like vin diesel and then 16
about 16 shots for real of espresso yeah
right all right so six does nothing
yeah
because cocaine is too scary because
cocaine is too scary yeah do coke yeah
yeah that's probably the next step my
man what's this
no
how long have you been doing nicotine uh
since i was like 13. oh [ __ ]
dipping since i was yes but you were
used like dipping down it was just like
yeah fiberglass that and [ __ ] yeah i
don't like that why did you stop dipping
i did this morning
it's the first day in the morning so i'm
up at like 5 30 first thing i had to
make a the strongest coffee you've ever
seen and you're up at 5 30. yeah i have
kids do you sleep yeah oh yeah i go to
bed by nine usually unless i'm on the
road how do you sleep just with 16 shots
that doesn't faze me dude no his
adrenals are flattest pancakes
he's got like little they've atrophied
but there's nothing better than you like
i'm sorry
more crazy
me crazy you must be wild crazy cool
dude
freddie you're pushing us i know yeah
i'm trying to get you on the rogue train
though because i started with the same
ones you did yeah if you're looking for
flavor you're looking for flavor daddy
this is mint dude these i'm telling you
as far as flavor crush it i feel like
psychologically you're doing a couple
things i feel like psychologically like
he went and said do you think i have cta
football for you know 17 years fighting
for eight and the doctor goes hundred
percent you have a hundred percent cte
because what do i do he goes uh
basically take a lot of fish oil and
that's all we know he's like cool so
then then but i think
nicotine is good for your brain yes
that's why i started it nick king's good
for you i i i feel like they found with
like smokers like our grandparents [ __ ]
that were dying from smoking they found
out none of them had dementia or like
issues
they
brain
they did die but they were there
but they were older they're older
yeah so we'll see that's why i tell
myself we gotta get you on the rogue
train though i'll do it yeah yeah i'm
not tied to zen yeah yeah how many times
a day do you do that
uh
i don't know all day did you ever say do
you ever smoke cigarettes
i did when i tried to quit dip
but no i was never like a smoker yeah
are you a whiskey guy
no i don't like whiskey that much beer
just like beer yeah yeah you're like all
american [ __ ]
dude
i'm looking for a place to watch some
games grab a bear like
look good oh that's foreign squad
yeah you think jalen hurts is the answer
i was not sold on him but he looked good
he's a baller he looked good better than
[ __ ] went yeah i loved one me too
he's gonna do well he's gonna be good
i think he's good you think yeah he's
hurt again though he's all right he hurt
his foot in camp
and they said they thought he was gonna
be out for like six weeks you know like
when the egos won the super ball wence
was like
he's gonna be mvp got hurt nick foles
comes in yeah wins him the super ball
and everyone's like uh what do we do now
and he comes back then he gets hurt yeah
and then he's he just has it so it just
hasn't worked out yeah he just never got
it back but he's [ __ ] good he's a
good he's a great option for if if your
first if your first string gets hurt
right i mean
once the startup is
when when force comes in and does that
mean that they keep
wentz as as a backup or no he was a game
he was hurt okay he was hurt and that's
what [ __ ] the heels is they paid them
like yeah way too much money
yeah they trade them to the cults yeah
right yeah trade yeah for like a draft
pick yeah they're like oh sorry but
they're gonna have like three first
round draft picks next year the eagles
yeah they look alright do you play
football i did where i went what team
what team
i went to army and i quit yeah
are you in the army i went to the united
states military academy for three weeks
and realized it wasn't for you and yeah
i realized oh my god
you're working out you've got nice legs
he goes i just i just heard mumbling
peloton
yeah
i love politics
so you went to the out of high school
you went to the army yeah for football
go to army yeah they're really yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're good at football and uh
i quit and then i went to elon it's one
double a in north carolina and you play
ball played one year what position then
quit i played offensive guard oh damn i
was a guard you were big yeah it was big
like what was like three hundred points
yeah i used to be strong now and then
when and then down just gay
boy
now you're [ __ ] artistic now i'm an
artist yeah you're not as artistic you
know he has a [ __ ] journal
every day you do on the road
can you keep it down right in my journal
no way can you imagine what he's writing
he's probably like drawing pictures dude
i'm not talking about pictures of like
cats i feel like pictures are killing me
i just say that i mean i'm just honest
with myself yeah
he journals every day stick figures
he was making fun of my bag i got to get
rid of the bag he's right right one yeah
he's like i'll buy it from me dude i got
we got off the card
we're going to get starbucks first thing
you said
get rid of it
what are you carrying in there
a drone
yeah you bring it in you brought a
journal at least carrying a mask or
something you know
a knife in there a knife yeah
i have a knife i have a machete i don't
know if i'm allowed to say tim kennedy
tim kennedy had a fanny pack and i don't
know if you remember this we were like
what's in your fanny pack he's like well
let's take a look
knife
rope
gun like tin
because he's got to keep america safe
you keep doing what you you do and he'll
he'll do what he does he stresses yeah
he's fighting at the board right now he
goes it is it bad now you're just oh
terrible
yes nothing fake you've never heard of
tim kennedy i have heard it oh okay so
you so you played football at army yeah
played one year one year then you went
to then when did you then i quit and
they quit then when did comedy come like
were you on the right
yeah you're the funny guy well it's
because i sucked i had to be funny yeah
yeah yeah you got to be funny make
yourself the offensive line's usually
funny yeah yeah and then when you're the
worst offensive lineman you got to be
extra that's all i had so then you
then when did stand-up start you started
doing uh probably like two years later
yeah
a little later start right yeah i mean i
didn't say that but i was like 22
23 when i started shane tell us about
your special
he's like i'm so done with podcasting
yeah yeah yeah yeah promoting have you
been doing it yeah
you've done the whole game yes yeah
it is but that's all right but with your
i'll say this especially we don't i mean
we've highlighted i even talked about on
my instagram today
uh christa stefano tech chris is a good
buddy of mine he texts me goes dude
shane gill is special watch it oh yeah
that's nice yeah that's nice yeah chris
is a man it was great you know yeah when
it first started like right yeah you
gotta be in like comedy mood like my
kids were like running around they're
going outside okay let me just [ __ ]
check this out because i'm a fan of you
thanks and then it starts and i was like
all right it's good and then we get to
the trump stuff i was taking the whole
group oh yeah yeah i was like bro
yeah trump's funny
he's fun he's funny yeah
you will you see him at the evander
holyfield stuff i didn't even get to see
it what do you do
he he's like i'm uh i'm not even trying
you're the guy who does the best uh
impression of him but he goes i'm uh
he's like i've been friends with these
guys for years for years he goes i love
these guys like anderson silver i love
him and everyone's like
all right yeah
yeah he's like and he's trying to break
it down he's trying to because you know
he came from the 911 [ __ ] and then just
be lined in a private jet down to
florida he's a monster right he's on all
the adderall where the [ __ ] calling a
fight on 911 as the president
i didn't do anything i didn't do
anything sad fight but i didn't do
anything
you could make an argument trump did the
most american thing correct
commentator fight promote me yeah well
he also he also said he goes i i would
like to fight joe biden i think uh yeah
yeah
being in my clip was funny because i
beat him around yeah cnn's like is there
nothing less sacred now he that's like
he's jumping around
yeah they don't see him doesn't
understand they're making him more funny
correct yeah whenever
can you believe he said this it's like
yeah it's funny you're making it funny
and what cnn does is obviously they have
i mean their ratings are [ __ ]
terrible but what they do is when they
go after trump are now you know trump
kind of popped back up but now they're
going after rogan it's like you realize
when you do that yeah it brings more
fans to them because people people might
hate them but they really hate you
jordan peterson said that jordan
peterson on rogan said you know i hate
to say this out loud but i've made so
much money off of social justice
warriors because every time they protest
one of his his uh you know speeches
right back in support well they his
patreon goes off yeah so he just makes
so much money yeah it's like every time
you guys hate on me i make more it's the
same with haters on youtube or whatever
it is like you guys realize when you
leave comments i make money correct like
that's how this game works it's crazy so
you guys dislike it or leaving comments
it puts money in my pocket yes so keep
it up
it's just it's just good promotion man
people know how
i thought it was ballsy to release it on
youtube let's take a little break from
chatting with my main man shane gillis
because guess what man it's 20 21 and
mental health is finally a thing so many
people are struggling right now and
aren't feeling like they're normal
selves and you don't have to feel like
that all the time man there's actual
people that can help i'm talking about
licensed professional therapists you
don't need to go in an office you can
call in you can set up call times to
take care of this it helps when you talk
to a professional who they've heard
these stories they know how to help they
know exactly what to say they help you
navigate this crazy world we live in
it's all about your mental space
whatever you need man whatever you need
it's not uh there's no reason to be
ashamed about it everybody struggles
with this stuff you deserve to be happy
and better help wants that for you all
right better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
but if you don't want to see anyone you
don't have to you can just talk to them
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and start communicating with
your therapist in under 48 hours join
the millions of people who are seeing
what therapy is really about see if it's
for you because you are your greatest
asset this episode of fire and kid is
brought to you by better help all right
and you listeners and viewers of firing
the kid get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com fighter that's
betterhelp.com fighter
you know the insurance system and can be
tough man a lot of y'all got those high
deductibles your health insurance plan
you know you're on the hook for
thousands of dollars co-pays premiums
it's not good man it's not good it's
like you're still shopping at
blockbuster and you didn't know netflix
is there man listen it isn't health
insurance it's a better way to pay
medical expenses i'm talking about crowd
health crowd health a place where you
get simple flexible affordable way to
pay for your health care without
breaking the bank it's flexible
membership as a monthly subscription
start or stop when it's convenient for
you all right crowdhealth lowers your
monthly healthcare costs and you can see
any doctor you want straight up it's
simple you can use their app find any
doctor in the country rank from one star
to five star probably don't go the one
star uh scan bills and throw them away
crowd health takes it from there press
the button and receive virtual care
anytime anywhere crowdhealth is
available to offer amazing prices
because of his community of health
conscious members and for limit time the
final kid listeners and viewers you get
your first month free and after you've
been a member crowd health will include
a fitness wearable that's 30 days try
risk-free plus the fitness wearable just
go to join crowdhealth.com fit enter the
code fighter at sign up that's join
crowdhealth.com fit promo code fighter
all right crowd health is not health
insurance it's a community-powered
alternative terms conditions may apply
it's just good promotion man people know
how uh i i thought it was ballsy to
release it on youtube because it used to
be this thing right if you released a
special on youtube it's like everyone
passed on the guy yeah yeah yeah
but now i think with mark norman did you
hear his special was like the third most
watched special of the year yeah like
his blew up and so i think more like
legit comics like yourself like uh you
know norman those guys like more people
do that then i think it's gonna get take
a big dog like rogan somebody's also
gonna do it because if you want the most
eyeballs you wanna sell the most tickets
it's youtube man yeah i mean greg yeah
it's free it's right there it's on your
phone how did youtube was there well i
i didn't have a choice
nobody was buying my special you know
what though but but i don't it's not
because i was happy with it's not
because you're not a talented comic the
subject you talked about i even touched
rogue i'm like dude there's no way
netflix would [ __ ] yeah okay this like
the stuff he talks about which is
hilarious there's like there's he got
dicey yeah i mean you still see blow
back from that other [ __ ] sure yeah
yeah slightly only only in like the
industry yeah only in hollywood yeah
like only if like like trying to sell
like the sketch show or a show we made
yeah people will be like they bring that
i mean the jeopardy host had to step
down because he literally yeah ten years
ago on a podcast called a girl a booth
hoe yeah a booth [ __ ] oh well he's
saying oh you were a booth hoe like he
was just saying when you're at it when
you're at a convention center in the
booth and he just kind of said that and
then then i guess he fat shamed or he
said something problematic about
something and he was a monster people
loved him yeah he wasn't necessarily
calling her who's just saying no people
it was years ago ten years ago he had to
step down from as an executive producer
and a host
like and then and you are mistaking me
was apologize my boy michael davey's
running now though so she'll see
but uh jeopardy yeah
this show's about to take
a year 50
young audience
but for you with the blowback like at
some point you just got to say [ __ ]
hollywood like your sketch show
you know
where would you who do you want to sell
to you know i'm saying like you're in a
different lane
yeah
we can just keep making stuff yeah it
doesn't matter and you just sell your
tickets on the road yeah make a lot of
money and it's in the sketch shows all
it's all in-house it's like yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's interesting uh yeah it's
just our you have a team everything yeah
yeah yeah those are all guys from philly
yeah [ __ ] your friends just buddies
hanging yeah it's fun it's so much fun
it's very fun it's a lot of work though
isn't it coming up with funny well i
don't mckiever the guy john mckeever
writes right he's the writer he's the
writer director the girl is brilliant
kyla yeah she's crazy she's so funny
yeah that's uh six's girlfriend oh it is
yeah i love brother is she a comic
no she's just a love comic not an actor
none of that oh she's my comedian's
girlfriend hopefully not get her in here
she's hilarious that's [ __ ]
sketch with trump and maybe maybe she
should emcee when brian six is featuring
yeah yeah well i don't know how she'd do
oh yeah yeah that might be your skill
set well i
so he does this trump speed dating thing
she sits down she's oh
that's why i was like oh damn she's
that's when i was like oh damn this
girl's she's a legit actress yeah well
that's because i was like should she go
for saturday night live after this it's
kind of i don't want to [ __ ] on kyla
because i love kyla but that's like who
she is kind of oh interesting so like
when she sat down she some of those
lines she was actually [ __ ] up
and we were like no this is good there's
like keep it yeah it looks real happy
actually yeah it was great
[ __ ] amazing you gotta
yeah she's like pro trump
everything we put her in she's really
[ __ ] funny some people just have yeah
she to me she's like your special socks
for sure like when i watch it like all
you guys are brilliant but she's like
the specialist she's just a crazy lady
yeah she's like crazy lady yeah
yeah man that's dope brother
why are you grabbing me how do you guys
know each other uh we met claustrophobic
clusterfest afl i think and jfl we were
on the
like up next yeah
comedy central's clusterfest and then
was that new faces
jfl two or three two uh two or three i
think three yeah
jfl didn't do it this year because of
covered right something like that no
they did something too
because it was the one before it was
2019 yeah yeah yeah
in uh
not vancouver right
yeah
no we did the montreal but yeah yeah i
don't know we just became homies because
i heard a lot about him uh before
everyone was i don't know when
when i posted i was doing the
clusterfest we were like yo you got to
meet shane gillis like you guys would be
boys or whatever and we are just
wow
when somebody does that that's hard to
figure out
like the hobbies yeah i heard about you
because obviously schultzy's my boy tim
dillon chrissy d
and then i was like there's all these
like monsters out there man you guys
just need to [ __ ] start doing stuff
yeah guys i know everyone's doing stuff
and everyone just leapfrogged us yeah
like everyone's blowing up and then all
of them are like dude yeah i see shane
gillis i'm like really that's nice
that's when i looked you up thanks man
there is a whole new york thing now you
guys are all roughly the same age all
coming up together yeah it's pretty cool
but all like taking time taking over
yeah
like think about schultz yeah schultz
can probably play math square garden
next year like yeah sells
great you have any tickets he sells
crazy it's [ __ ] nuts well you have
schultzy then tim dillon i mean biggest
patreon there is and he sells stupid
tickets we have the same agent you find
out his ticket sales that hurt your
feelings
and then you know then you got chrissy d
doing his goddamn thing blowing up and
then you know you're the guy man yeah
this is because you're doing you're
about to do your first weekend since you
did your special yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah was nate bart godzilla with
you guys in new york he was older
he was older yeah it's pretty wild man
to watch yeah there's like harnessing
social media and the way you guys are
coming together plus new york holds you
to a high standard i mean new york is
just like you can take a cab and hang
out at that club and then do like five
sets in a night yeah and and there's
something about new york where if you
get too happy with yourself or it
becomes too commercial or whatever you
get called on the mat so i don't know if
it's still that way it is but there is
still that sort of there's a purity
there there's a there's a standard there
yeah and you're kind of in the way
because pride being like like yeah like
comic yeah i get that but then if you
noodle every night you know what i'm
saying yeah that's i think that's the
100 yeah that was like the hold up with
like the la guys doing all the promo and
podcasts and merch
and then the new york guys were like
[ __ ] that yeah yeah yeah it's like it's
always been that way
yeah builds a resentment you kind of
want to hold on to some of that like i
always feel like because new york
there's a reason well it's not just grit
it's like
you you at the end of the day when
you're sitting around that table at the
comedy cellar or wherever you go yeah it
you know you got colin quinn you got
louis ck you got all the old dudes
who've been doing it forever and and a
lot of guys who haven't heard of that
are murderers like grier barnes is a
[ __ ] murderer and all those guys so
what happens is like they'll kind of let
you know oh they'll let you know you
know what i mean they'll let you know if
you start getting
i don't know
yeah and also just a little too
um
it's almost like a like like so so
you'll see some people who can write a
really good song and there are tricks
and hooks and rhymes to it and it's real
commercial
then you see somebody who's doing
something different with music you know
and that's that
you're always expected to keep
it that way sure i guess but but i think
there's something to it because
like you because you can be a grinder
you can be that kind of comic and then
still also update with the time because
then you get a guy like kevin hart sure
andrew schultz yeah i'm saying
you need both yeah you have to yeah you
absolutely otherwise you are that's
exactly right well you should be playing
you know yeah you're going to crush it
at the you know the seller or the store
but all right not pay your rent yeah
yeah
you get respect from everybody but it's
like i think that the one thing that
that i've always struggled with as you
know is just the fact that a huge part
of your job is figuring out how to
promote how to be relevant yeah
yeah and i
have trouble with yeah yeah i have
trouble with that i hate it i do too and
you got to do it you have to do it
but i feel like you yeah i feel like you
do pretty good i try not to do it yeah
which is the worst but it's like
authentic to you it's like it's shane
that's the way shane would promote yeah
it's because now it's a youtube special
so i have yeah i have to if i put you on
the spot i was like shane
tell us about your special you gotta i'm
gonna give you i'll give you 20 seconds
ready
like real press dude i stopped doing it
like dude some of them asking those fake
questions to to right they've you ever
had that where they go uh give us some
lead in questions so that you can do
some bits
at night i'm like
i'm not doing it
give us a joke here let's give people a
little taste we're gonna see it and i'm
like what yeah my sister does heroin
exactly i stopped doing it yeah the
number one question right so you you got
to tell us brad what what's tougher get
inside that octagon or get on stage
showing jokes go oh [ __ ] yeah that's
actually what's the answer it's all
that's a good question
it's got to be the octagon that's going
to be the scariest thing in the [ __ ]
world they're both scary man yeah i mean
dude it's brutal yeah
it's terrifying the one thing about him
is i remember i never i i felt bad i did
it we were in seattle and it was like
1800 people in a in a theater and we
were doing uh
we were doing i don't know what it was
we were doing a live podcast
and brandon had
zero experience in front of people like
zero and but he was like let's do live
podcast so
so i i remember i kind of was like
you're gonna go out i'm gonna be i'm
gonna pretend to be late you're gonna go
out and tell a story
and you're gonna be alone on stage and i
kind of just pushed him out there yeah
and he was like and and he did like you
did a couple breathing exercises i think
you learned from navy seals yeah you
must
and you just go out there and did really
well and then i remember i was like i
shouldn't have done that to you you know
i shouldn't have that's a [ __ ] big
thing because if you've never done that
yeah that's that's a disas that's
terrifying so he did great
and
and then later on we were talking you're
like i've been getting out there in my
underwear against monsters and they lock
a cage
and
you got to come out and you could die
and i think once you face that it's a
it's you know i don't know it's just
different it got you ready yeah i get
you ready especially like jumping into
the deep and get you ready everyone's a
girl you skipped open mics are you
talking about with other disgruntled
comics yeah
yeah i was doing 1400 people [ __ ]
sold out shows he's a beast man super
beast he's [ __ ] crazy
yeah
it's it's i always said that it's it
when you can't say that it was very
different for you first of all you've
been podcasting a long time
you uh you just came up you come up in
the philly scene and then go to new york
yeah
yeah so it was yeah philly's no no i
didn't do i didn't do the mics in new
york
ever so that was that was kind of
that was an interesting way to do it
most people you moved to new york and
you have to work your way up i was
already like because soda and jay
were already taking me on the road and
using me
and i waited a long time man big j big j
i waited a long time before i moved i
moved when i moved to new york like two
years ago three years ago oh but before
that you were in philadelphia it was
just in philly
your home club there was about the
helium yeah that's great function i love
that [ __ ] club
is [ __ ] amazing
suddenly you were just going around
there and then you're going where'd you
meet big j and uh when they were at
healing i would i featured for him oh
damn yeah i like soda took me on the
road and then jay took me so does the
denver boy man yeah that's my guy wait
so they already knew about you and
philly the club booked you and was like
club booked me got it now now i don't
know if you know this but i'm going to
do denver coming up here and you got to
be vaccinated
or show your proof of a negative cova
test that's the first time i've
no i'm saying the crowd does i know yeah
i didn't know that you'll probably see
it that's the first time i've seen this
i've dealt with it i had to deal with it
previously you'll and it's just what it
is you see about a
five to ten percent drop off on ticket
sales okay mm-hmm yeah because people
but denver's like eighty-five nine
percent vaccinating so demo shipping
really when you go other places can you
get dicey but then you gotta show
basically proof on your phone i guess
right
i don't know how they're doing there's
like no like system like they haven't i
saw that yesterday
yeah i don't know i just got to make a
thing about it but i don't know it's
interesting they have a qr code that you
can scan and show your vaccine thing i'm
pretty sure on your qr code yeah yeah
because in denver they take your phone
like have you you know in denver comedy
works yeah which is great yeah it's such
a nice i love it because it focuses the
audience it's it's amazing yeah well
think when you're out i mean i i'm not
that addicted to my phone but people i
don't have friends who are it's like you
go to i mean justin david you go you got
to lunch on the road and they're like
just on their phone like dude you could
be you'd be doing stamp in iraq you're
on the beach in san diego dude get off
the phone when we have kids bubba when
you have kids if if you have a 13 year
old daughter
she's on her phone she's tick tock
anime the whole world her friends you're
competing with everything yeah i don't
play that [ __ ] tiger gets his ipad
you know once a week yeah and you're
smart yeah and you're smart because
that's what we started doing about kids
you know it's like no no because it's
addictive it's made to be it's made to
be yeah it's made to get into your brain
yeah you're made to be addictive it's
it's like uh
it's just like even though the the the
moving like you know how on uh twitter
how you do this that move is for
like like slot machines it's addictive
yeah yes
yes like it's all and then when you tell
your kid you they can't play on it they
have some withdrawal symptoms they they
act like a junkie they'll be like they
get irritable and angry and you're just
like hey well i i've never felt older
than the last night i went to my son's
first teacher-parent conference and i
dressed up like a [ __ ] dad i had
tackies on and [ __ ] nice and i was
sitting there i'm sitting in like you
are dead yeah i just start dressing like
that
he likes fashion too much [ __ ]
you guys all love fans you don't give a
[ __ ] huh no
black socks
i walked in i was like yeah he said this
outfit on every pocket i'm the same
person
jim shorts
i like the adidas slippers those are my
favorite thanks they look comfortable as
[ __ ] thanks bro no
you look like the quality control
offense coordinator for the notre dame
that's that's what i'm doing you know
like you have the pain it's all i care
about yeah you're a notre dame fan from
philly
why
uh my grandpa and cousin played fair
point yeah yeah there you go yeah that's
a connection yeah my grandpa was ct'd
bad bad
see i didn't know i just told this it's
uh
he
every story i ever heard of my grandpa
was him like fighting people
all he did was attack people and then
like every story like he'd be punching
cars
he was an animal and he was like six
five he was huge and uh
when he died he had a heart attack and
then
he woke up on the operating table out of
the anesthesia and tried to fight like
the nurses his heart exploded
and then uh so nobody in my family ever
put it together and then they showed me
this newspaper clipping from like the
20s when he was playing that he was held
out of
against purdue he couldn't play because
of a head injury and if you have a head
injury in the 20s
through your [ __ ] head like you like
practice well when you have a brain my
friend had a traumatic brain injury fell
out of a van and hit the back of his
head and they had to strap him down when
i went to see him in the hospital he was
strapped to the gurney i was like why is
he strapped to the ground they go well
when he comes too he'll come too
periodically when he wakes up he tries
to fight us because he brews the front
of his brain oh no and so there's two
things that happen when you get
concussed like it's it it is what it is
it just i don't know i'm sure maybe it's
genetic or something but when you get
concussed either you get really
aggressive and you want to fight like
your grandpa is trying to kill everybody
or you get really emotional i cry yeah
the times i've been knocked out
yeah
you have any crazy injuries uh no i tore
my
mcl and lcu did you did you nothing with
the head did you get many concussions
playing football i played o-line so it
was like they say that's the worst yeah
it's just slow and gradual yeah but it
was you never got like your bell right
you know yeah yeah yeah how old are you
i'm 33. so i mean similar but growing up
like playing pop one or yeah when you
get to you're like oh you got his bell
rung like get back in there yeah like
now you're thinking about like hey hey
dumbass yeah bellrung means i shouldn't
be practicing yeah how often would you
get your bell wrong because you're big
in college was tough playing playing
fullback dude that must have my friend
played fullback he had to stay he had
like seven concussions in like one
season did you ever it was just non-stop
yeah you did oh and football oh yeah
yeah oh yeah and you knew yeah i was
just crashing fullback for big 12x crazy
the big 12. that's the that's the
because that's the position like
just middle linebackers and fullbacks
over and over so i was full back in the
big 12 and then i was the wedge breaker
on special oh my god and i was the wedge
they were like this white guy just get
his big ass on there he'll be okay
and and what they used to do he used to
spar then he used to fight like in the
ufc then what they used to do during
film
terrible dude i'm on so much supplements
anyways uh what they used to do in film
on mondays after the game they'd have
like a whole like everyone would laugh
because get like my bell rung i'd light
some guy up yeah like dude i got a
headache yeah like yeah this is great
man i'm like yeah no doubt yeah what
does this wedge breaker mean again so i
explained it take off they got rid of
this they got ready they don't even have
it in football it's so dangerous it was
the most dangerous that's how dangerous
it is yeah they don't have it there's
rules
yeah yeah so hold on so you know so
let's say the start of the game there's
a team that the kickoff team kicks the
ball yep so there's the return man yeah
from the return man is a wedge of human
beings
that that go like try to block so he can
score a touchdown okay yeah but then
there's a guy who's a kamikaze guy that
runs to break that wedge so those guys
can't block yeah his job is literally to
dive straight into that wall and it's
sprinting
50 yards into each other i mean it's
it's yeah they got rid of and you're
there video of this i mean
i'm sure i mean i don't know how the
[ __ ] you're you i mean you're trying to
hit with eyes i feel you you were you're
fine you
feel good you're trying to hit with your
with your arms and your shoulders first
right no [ __ ]
no you don't know what i can't think of
anything worse i i just not built for
this it was my thing you know what's
like your thing yeah so it was like your
thing yeah yeah so when we're playing
like texas a big 12 championship like oh
i'm gonna light this [ __ ] dude
because there was another guy who was
going to meet halfway
yeah they have a crazy guy too of course
that's what i mean that's crazy
you know it was like ronnie lott i was
watching this thing on ronnie a lot
ronnie lot would knock himself out
ronnie lott would [ __ ] hate you and
and go out
like he would just throw him if you if
you youtube wedge breaker you'll see
these they're literally like the
japanese pilots just [ __ ] flying into
the goddamn kamikaze
does anybody know what kamikaze means
crazy divine wind
[Laughter]
thank you it's funny
to
uh what you're gonna see at the plus so
you see and see he catch it see the two
guys grab arms yeah where are you what
to block for the ball i'm the big white
guy in the left okay it's a foul as well
so there's actually this isn't even a
good one two man wedges that are formed
on this planet see how those two guys
come together yeah yeah yeah yeah
wedge rewind that watch this dude get
cracked back top
he cuts over from alabama two here one
that doesn't blind sideways yeah there's
a dude who runs to the left right to
left
and that's clearly boom oh my god back
up the field
um what you're going to see at the plus
45 two players come together damn
shoulder to shoulder uh to block for the
ball carrier and so that is a foul as
well why is that actually two
why is that a foul
when it was a longer one you were the
middle
yeah and you just wait for the guy to
like blow you up but i was the guy that
would blow it up too yeah so i got him
both you're just spending a lot of time
[ __ ] helmet on helmet with other
dudes yeah yeah those guys are yeah that
was like the scariest guy on the team
though yeah i hated blocking those dudes
the worst there was like there were
middle linebackers that were like that
that would like lead with their helmet
yeah and i played offensive line so like
you're kind of like we played zone
blocking so i was always kind of upright
not really firing hell and dudes would
just dive straight into your [ __ ]
head it's nuts it was terrible and you
can't leave with the helmet anymore
this is what they say right
as an offensive lineman you kind of can
be that's not how nobody blocks that way
yeah you block with your hands yeah oh
so was your dream to go the nfl
uh are you that guy
you knew
i knew you got the army did you know it
in high school did you in high school i
knew i was not going oh good for you
yeah most guys i ran like a five seven
forty i was like
i'm not going anywhere this is
what's average for someone in that
position
now they run like four nines yeah oh
it's terrible like it used to be it used
to be like a freak if you're like 349.
now there's four lines every year and
there's three hundred people no one's
running a [ __ ] five that's yeah they
no they are they are it's stupid they
even make them run 40 yards but there's
there's a lot of your lateral motion too
the side to side motion that they do for
o lineman yeah the 510
five yeah the
i ran like i went to this combine at
west virginia
and ran easily the slowest 40 in the
entire combine and i was just like it's
so embarrassing
because you run they're all it's so
important because everyone knows there's
a whole group and they're like five
seven seven you're like
there was a slow twitch muscle over here
it was so slow dude you have to do the
uh
225 yeah
225 that's stupid for linemen too yeah
they should be doing 315. yeah would you
you get a lot i did i forget
you you know you really can't work on
speed though it's one of those things
you either have or you don't you can get
better you know there's techniques
there's techniques but yeah
buddy there was a there was a kid from
there was a west virginia player because
they had the players from west virginia
were like helping i think it was like
scout.com or something and
the dude who timed me was like damn like
i heard him time it was like damn
like
those times
between us
like chappelle was like i ran a 4-3 in
high school
anybody i've been around the game i go
chapelle your coach told you that yeah
and i don't think you're a liar but i
promise you you did yeah because that
was because everybody gets hand-timed
and they're like oh i ran a five five or
four or five in high school it's like
you're in a fourth generation i promise
you didn't you but i love you the coach
who told you that doesn't know what he's
doing and lied to you but in your head
you thought you were running for well
because it was like an affordable right
it was like the talk of the time jump
talking to town or whatever it was crazy
dude i might have set records at this
camp it's the worst fight of all time
dude when you have children you you hope
it is hope that maybe your kids are
going to be i don't know something
physically special right yeah now i'm me
you have boys i got boys and uh and so
i'm in utah and there is a olympic gold
medal swimmer sprinter i can't remember
her name she's pretty well known
she's a swimmer and she does uh
a lot of the uh announcing don't do that
i know
downhill skier right
both of them are just a couple of like
you see them and you go well you look
different right yeah yeah so my kids
i was it but they're skiers i would yeah
but they're but he's a great he's a
little guy he's a little gay hold on
gold medalist
i know but still yeah he's still a very
good athlete right skiing member is a
world sport so he is you know he's still
winning you can win goldwin badminton
or a lot of gold medals i would suggest
that downhill skiing is a real sport
though of course those guys yeah you got
to be special i mean he's still i looked
at his body and i remember he's an
outlier skier for sure yeah but it's
just all legs and ass and just muscular
as [ __ ] and i'm like he was like a like
a downhill like that they're big they're
always strong either way i [ __ ] uh i
play tag with
my i'm it and it's my kids and and their
kids and they're the same age same age
dude
the difference in challenges
i had to run as fast as i could this
game was eight i had like action it was
astonishing how fast they were it's like
when i went ran sprints i've done it
twice against nfl
these nfl guys at tark trains yeah it's
don't do that but yeah no don't do that
yeah you were running sprints against
them i have on video will you doing i
look like i'm standing you just you just
try it i want you to want to see it's
like pro versus joe's i want to see how
fast i am i've done it many times and
i'll tell you what's weird or you don't
have kids right shane no you have a girl
i do all right yeah so you're working
that way yeah but uh you got to it's
weird when you have kids because
tiger's and jit so i take him twice a
week now and they're doing take now
they're they're at the level because
he's two striped now two striped white
belt that's the level where they start
on the feet and do take downs oh boy so
me and tiger uh like i'll just go over a
certain like single leg and grip and
stuff with like and i don't give him too
much when i'm like dude when he comes at
you grab the leg run through and you
know i just kind of barely coach him on
it and then last week was the first time
real life takedowns and dude i don't
know if it's something in his dna or
just because it was in my dna oh yeah
the double leg that i did was my
signature double leg he takes this
[ __ ] eight-year-old and single legs
and flares it out and double eggs them
into the goddamn mat coach is like jesus
christ and they looked at me like dude
yeah i was like yeah i did not show him
that much what's your chance that's
interesting
i don't know if it's just his neck is he
just downloaded the data the kid looks
like he does neck exercises like he's
got high calves he's got a neck when he
was four years he's built like a
stingray when he was four years we used
to we used to go to this ma our friend
owns a uh uh parkour parkour gym
so tiger would be four years old and
you'd watch this kid
you'd watch him run he would never get
tired and he would just run
no it stinks
backflips and all that [ __ ] those
parkour guys are nuts i'm like how do
you make money dude
those are athletes
now those guys are athletes let's do a
flip on like while they're up
when that goes wrong that must [ __ ]
go right now oh yeah
that's the main guy that guy who's like
famous did where he jumped from the
railing and landed
it's so horrifying like jumped what
looks like 50 feet and lands on a small
disc like that and if you fall you
you're [ __ ] yeah you're like scaling
the great [ __ ] wall china and [ __ ]
but they're up like a million feet and i
was like like the number one guy's like
dude you know
you're making a living to us he's like
oh yeah dude and then i walked away i
talked to his manager he's like you know
he's not 70 grandmother
it's like a teacher's sound like
you know we're getting starbucks i know
right yeah substitute teachers
yeah i mean yeah i guess i mean some
people just get uh it's it's the juice
you're doing it for the juice right yeah
yeah
no some of those [ __ ] are a
little bit older
yeah yeah yeah just like well they have
major competitions you know oh yeah girl
yeah competition for that my kids was uh
had won the competition in italy or
something like that sure
she had legs like you know i mean
jumping over rails and [ __ ] in italy
yeah
yeah they show you the videos you're
like yeah no you're you're flipping over
buildings yes
it is i mean obviously it's impressive
it's like it is i just have no you know
it's just yeah i have no interest i'm
like why don't you do something with it
yeah yeah well there are people that can
climb i think it's insane where they
just climb they they the buildings yeah
they well the two walls will be here and
they can just climb up a hundred feet
they should just be thieves that's what
i'm saying steal people's purses it's
probably worth it run or be like a real
like spider-man or some [ __ ] like like
fight crime that's probably where it
really came from they just saw
spider-man was like [ __ ] it i got it
it's very strange man
it's so weird that's how i started doing
backflips [ __ ] watching power rangers
really yeah i was just like oh [ __ ] it i
got it because that's too much power
rangers it does not hold up no oh i
haven't watched it it doesn't hold up
oh my god it is so big
yeah yeah it's so late back in the day
that [ __ ] was tight yeah it was like
funny to think of you putting it on
being like all right let's see if this
holds up
i was trying to move you guys yeah
and i was like oh wow that you don't
realize how gay power rings like all
right let's not
it's not all kids stuff and they do the
morphing time yeah stuff is all it's
very good yeah but now because kids are
gay
all kids are getting all kids are gay
they start off gay yeah
that's what they're teaching schools now
in l.a yeah yeah well now kids have
these crazy video games where they're
playing each other
virtually so they they're so my buddy
walked by like you broke that news like
it's i know no but my buddies are
playing each other online and listen to
this shane they're not in the same house
our buddy though walked by that by his
kid's room he goes take a piss it's five
in the morning you're dropping in bombs
he hears me no no
that's what yeah
on those games
like where does this come in there's
everywhere
oh my god major racism no but it's five
in the morning he just hears his twelve
year old
yeah dude
and he goes you [ __ ] you've been
up all night he's been up all night
playing
with the thing and the [ __ ] guns and
all that stuff and he just doesn't go to
sleep we used to me and my friend jamal
used to play call of duty and one time
we were playing it together jabal's a
white kid small is african-american
[Laughter]
and uh this dude was just screaming the
n-word and it's just me and jamal
sitting there like
and that weird and then eventually i was
like
this is great i was like does that like
does that like bother you anything i
knew you're gonna say some gay [ __ ] like
you got like mad at me like does that
affect you
are you doing the okay yeah yeah i'll
[ __ ] you man yeah cause it's like what
are you going to do about it
black player just like young kids
dropping and you're like what the [ __ ]
you know that's how we end racism
even those big gamers like they go like
the cancer culture they'll go back to
when they were young and they'll find
out they dropped the bomb pewdiepie got
one that was pretty rough
there's a guy that used to be like the
gamer uh-huh pdq is it pdp pewdiepie
yeah i think it was pewdiepie maybe i
got the wrong guy but there was yeah he
hit a like he just called a guy the n
word like on his live stream
and then he was like no i'm sorry yeah
damn
damn yeah and [ __ ] is his gaming
career no no he's back
the game
yeah we've all heard it yeah yeah that's
swedish you know or something yeah
they're obviously they get a pass they
get yeah i give them a pass
the swedes are good
they're good swedish people it's weird
where gaming's gonna go in like 10 years
virtual virtual they're already doing
you put those [ __ ] helmets on but i
[ __ ] was playing ping pong
at this stupid [ __ ] thing that my son
has and i'm i'm in i'm in this house and
you know my old house with the cement
floors and stuff and the the ball
gets hits the net and it rolls you want
to pick it up i went to [ __ ] reach
for it and i fell over
it makes you wonder if we're actually
living in a [ __ ] hyper simulated
reality right now i wonder it's so weird
man
it's so [ __ ] weird is is new york
locked down like uh
listen the me the media makes la seem
like north korea but yeah it's actually
not too bad here is new york pretty
locked down similar to here yeah just
not as bad you guys suck where they're
like
when we're in like the height of it i
was talking to schulte about it and he
moved to miami he was like yeah they
were like yeah you can eat outdoor
outdoor dining is open he's like dude
it's [ __ ] snow yeah yeah
who's gonna [ __ ] eat outside right he's
like so they may seem like oh all good
small business can stay open you can eat
outside he's like nobody wants to [ __ ]
you talking about in new york new york
yeah they just built
into the stream right they built rooms
and said it was outside yeah like just
because it was shitty they were like and
then the cellar and the there's no
comedy going down that was yeah that was
all close now there is no right now it's
back yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now it's
fully you just gotta be back
fully you gotta be fully backed up to
get in yeah yeah
and so you have to show that on your
phone every time yeah they have to show
that
the people
yeah the fans do yes but no ideas to
vote
no
did you when you were doing your special
did you were you ner did you find
yourself kind of nervous about
dan do you feel like you have to dance
around subjects or or jesse especially i
did um i saw it yeah there's no yeah no
no i i no i don't think yeah okay i
don't think so yeah that's your brand
though yeah
i mean i didn't feel that from you i
watched it especially
you know yeah no i don't i don't think
yeah it is it does kind of get annoying
like when i like perform i'm used to
performing in new york like during the
week i'm in new york yeah so it's all
liberal yeah and it's very fun to go on
stage and be like yo trump rules yeah
just to have them all yeah yeah yeah but
then you go on the road i'm like yo
trump rules and the whole crowd yeah
well this isn't funny now
it's not funny
yeah yeah
yeah with my my stuff now i'm trying to
show the the similarities and the
differences but i'm not drawing sides
like i'm trying to show the folly on
both sides but whenever i whenever i
like i notice in my crowds when i make
fun of like the liberals
and then then i'm going to make fun of
the conservatives but they don't know
you
yeah yeah that's kind of crazy yeah our
boy uh david lucas who goes on before
chappelle with me he literally comes out
goes hey am i the only one that misses
trump here yeah anywhere we go yeah
anywhere crazy
certain markets go crazy in certain
markets i'm a youth but a rough night
yeah who who got weird about it where
were we
at uh oklahoma oklahoma yeah so which is
weird oklahoma yes yeah start talking
some of those states like i did uh
richmond virginia and you would think
like all right these but there's there's
like little pockets in
red states that are very liberal
you know what i mean i didn't think you
know they're surrounded by it so they're
like ultra liberal
yeah you know what i mean yeah depends
on where you go that's what's surprising
if it's more combative yeah it's it they
get defensive you know that actually
makes sense but like even he did in
austin and because you think texas you
think red technology
but in austin's austin little l.a yeah
watson's purple more blue you guys when
he did it there it was like they're like
it's the same in arizona there's like
small like liberal pockets in like
arizona's [ __ ] red but there's has
its small pockets of you know well
there's also like uh in schools all
these kids are being challenged with new
narratives it's not how we grew up where
you learn u.s history it's really tricky
now for them to teach because what
happens is as a teacher i just got into
this yesterday as a teacher you're
teaching elementary school if you're
going to teach us history you got the
question becomes if you start teaching
from 1776
and not 1619 you will have stu you'll
have parents
who go
wait you know they and they can be white
or whatever they have their liberal
point of view and it becomes a debate
it's really tricky for the teacher to
have to deal with so now the teacher
teaches if you teach about being a
global citizen and being ra racism
if you bring up the term anti-racist
it's supercharged versus not racist and
these are that in elementary school bro
i just was
yeah
i'm dealing with that in in my
elementary school so it it becomes a
whole [ __ ] thing and it's a balancing
act so what's going on in fifth grade
yeah so young people now yeah he's
actually i'm sorry he's in fourth young
people now are are i mean are being
educated it's just different and social
media is setting a different standard
they're just public shaming is a real
thing
and it's keeping people there's people
yeah
far away far away stare
it's a very powerful thing because with
young people now there's call out
culture
and call in culture which is the idea of
i'll call you out in front of everybody
or i might call you in first is it for a
private this is happening in schools so
now some student says you didn't
recognize my identity or whatever it
might be and you're being called in so
now that kid calls you in
with the teacher
and you've been called in now the next
step is to be called out in front of
everybody oh man so what happens is with
people what's the fight it's a lot to
deal with i'm like yeah you call me in
we're gonna fight correct correct that's
what we're gonna do now if you do no now
now you can't you're out of school
you're out of school but also it's a lot
it's a lot to deal with man because like
how do you how do you navigate that so
what happens when it's on the page kids
are becoming there's a puritanical
there's there is a new puritanism in a
way because everybody is afraid everyone
i i got into it a little bit yesterday
with this teacher the way she was
teaching she was teaching she was
teaching white teacher yes and she was
teaching she had a book on anti-racism
anti-racism versus not being racist very
strong
yes it's a very strong political point
of view it's insane and what was
interesting was i was the only one to
voice it and i could tell some parents
were buttholes got tight into it other
parents got super tight obviously nobody
wants to say that to be if if they did
that when me and my friends were in
fourth grade it'd be so long it'd be so
of course i mean i remember like we had
teachers like telling us about gay
people
and we were delighted
it was so fun to say gay yeah we'd be
like
what is gay
i mean if we had a racism class yeah oh
dude well that's cool wait can i say
what are some words i'm not allowed
that's kind of what's i have a word i
want to know if it's racist that's
what's happening
with gender now you're talking about now
now you're you're describing somebody as
being a straight white cisgender male 1
you have to they have yeah explain it
but this is in your fourth grade bro
i don't want to get into this but too
much oh my god
well there are two things that can
happen one is
it becomes it's hard for on the teacher
it's hard on the teacher because they
they're being pushed they're being
pulled on one and everybody's having an
argument so now how do we teach right
how do we teach what is the standard
what's the truth i'm all first teaching
true american history okay not
whitewashed but these are kids i don't
know how to do it but what also happens
is exactly what you're saying dude like
my friend's kid my my my he goes it's a
nice butterfly and he goes he goes look
at him look at him look at him sitting
there on that pedal and his friend goes
his son goes dead
joking around goes how dare you
gender that butterflies excuse them
fourth grade but they're all [ __ ]
around now they're making fun of it oh
yeah oh yeah you start doing if you
start making it hush hush oh kids are
going to run bro yeah and also the kids
aren't dumb like my niece
like i was talking to her about it and
that she's in like seventh or eighth
grade and she's like
yeah there's like 10 bisexual kids
yeah it's like dude
you're in seventh grade yeah and five
kids who identify as trans yeah so they
they see who's do you know if you were a
kid you'd see like i'm not saying
they're weird for doing that but like
you know they're if a kid is like i'm
actually trans yeah yeah
[Laughter]
you just don't have friends
this is a move
back in my day you're called goth yeah
in one way or another it's just
it's just a lot man it's a lot
there is something about
there is a lot of talk in a lot of
schools
about capitalism
being essentially inherently racist
that's insane and you hear this all the
time that is the narrative on that side
of the equation so
you got to know when people like cloak
something that they're teaching and
we're just trying to all get along and
you go that's not what's going on yeah
you're teaching a strong political
agenda here yeah you have a bias you got
a box yeah you got it you got it you
can't have that you're trying to say
capitalism is racist it's a very common
thing now in the anti-racist far-left
movement you know whatever it might be
that capitalism and the structures of
even the western institutions all of
them are inherently
biased towards one
it's it's it's essentially a white
supremacy construct therefore it favors
only whites and so that may there may be
a debate there may be a conversation to
be had there hell yeah
i love it
yeah it's it's just when they start
teaching you know when you're ready for
the rogue big dog yeah it's good right
perfect
oh you're just one yeah dude you're
you're he's he's bullying no i'm not
this is not bullying he's a nickname
he's friendship this is friends this is
where that's stronger though same six
milligrams you just you just pull them
from your pouch yeah oh but maybe rogue
is a little better than your i think
rogues i've tried them all yeah what
flavor is this this is mango it's nice
isn't it nice it's nice i got you doug
yeah
better than the mint
i'm not gonna say better not yeah yeah
it's just too early
fair enough like this is disgusting
though mangoes mangoes great i don't
like mango the fruit really my girl eat
it mexican's [ __ ] like salt all over
in hot sauce
well that's why she's ruining it yeah
i've never been a mango sauce yeah why
don't you add some liver to it
this is sucky the mango itself is
[ __ ] delicious man
so you're going to war with teachers
i think it's time i think that's the
right move
i'm going to start speaking up
i will take a flag on a hell nobody else
wants to [ __ ] defend but then
the problem is then you're the crazy dad
and then then finn gets bullied at
school because they get the crazy dead
hey bubba i'm sure i'm sure there's
going to be a lot of stuff we'll see
what happens i'll keep you posted no no
just pull him out of that [ __ ] school
if he gets too crazy yeah you got to ask
yourself what you're willing to fight
for
yeah it's kind of just trying to change
up [ __ ]
i just think that i just think at the
end of the day everybody has something
they're willing to fight for and you
define yourself that way most of us get
to walk around not having to worry about
it problem with kids is
kids make you draw some lines oh big
time you know what i'm saying but new
york crowds are still here's his fourth
christopher columbus ruled
i'm gonna say it
god damn it my kid's not showing up on
griffin columbus day you guys don't
celebrate the collins dude though you
know indians were bad did you know that
you know you know they were great too
no that's not what i should get into jfk
what about mlk huh
[Laughter]
teacher's like
no that's the thing is you got to be
careful and you got to be fair right of
course but it's [ __ ] but you better
do your homework
yeah you better come correct you better
come correct you know that's all it's if
you're going to take this fight
you better have done your homework and
you better have read the people you're
disagreeing with luckily i have yeah you
kick ass in school
what do you mean like get good grades
and [ __ ]
yeah i did fine okay yeah
i liked history i studied you weren't
like validating history no but i got
into west point yeah that's a good thing
in school man yeah i did all right i was
a history major too yeah nice yeah yeah
yeah history's fun
it's interesting
[Laughter]
you must have got good grades if you
went to uh louisville right now to get
no [ __ ] good grades no no you're
still being baptized
i don't think louisville's oh wait like
you do cheering no so like so
cheerleader with the journal yeah just
[ __ ] you shade that's crazy dude
it was an anger man
yeah yeah yeah
i was telling him he's gotta get back on
the boots yeah he keeps staying i always
save the time yeah he's not pushing him
yeah he's like it's time
i want to see that i want to stay clean
he wants to see me punch people
naturally if you want some good whiskey
i guess i brought from montana no i'm
all right maybe yeah yeah yeah chappelle
you stick stay with me i know i was yeah
i'm a state but no uh
so
when i would for for louisville uh
i cheered at a junior college in texas
well i got
plastered and
got kicked off pretty much or wasn't
allowed to like try out again and [ __ ]
and so louisville had i wasn't finished
with junior college but louisville had a
program to where you could go to the
junior college it was like a transfer
program but you could go to the junior
college and cheer at the university
you're like the trail owns of
cheerleaders yeah yeah you're in cancer
in the locker room oh bro i was a
[ __ ] dude
did you watch that netflix cheer show
yeah yeah yep fantastic yeah fantastic
so that's i love that the school that
they talk about how much did you love
jerry i loved all the i loved all the
ladies and then they remembered all the
ladies they were ridiculous they were so
fantastic so hot and the remark was
crazy when they were celebrating at the
end of the ocean i was like i wish i was
in there
when they went to the beach i would have
run out with them
i think he works for notre dame
i knew we were gonna do it
yeah there was that one dime piece with
the with the crazy parents and she was
like the the best one remember oh yeah
she's like yeah yeah she's she's pretty
good really good
she's good yeah really really good she's
big on social media yeah and it was her
and then jerry was the one who was like
on ellen and hosting yeah he was doing
the oscar red carpet dude i followed a
bunch of those girls on instagram
i don't know what i thought nothing was
going to come out of it
they weren't going to be like oh who's
this
if you ladies want to come to a show let
me know that was so funny i liked those
[ __ ] pictures i got excited
i was like why is shane
that's so crazy i got really into it too
and then what what was the other one
with the the football team did it too
oh yeah it's like the same
yeah last chance it's so good see those
teams
they i've i watch it i've watched every
year i just re-watched season one
they're [ __ ] hilarious it's the best
the teams you played football yeah no
team on earth would act like this
every team dude it's unheard of if the
other team scores first
the whole team explodes
their attitudes were awful the coaches
were [ __ ] insane yeah well i watched
two of them and i didn't see i don't
think i don't think one player actually
lasted in a d1 program am i right uh no
no they do yeah it's a monster it's a
powerhouse for that yeah yeah but uh
what's the difference from nfl they went
on to play big time ball they did oh
yeah nfl yeah yeah no i'm saying college
i think like legarrette florida stayed
they'd be like dude
all you got to do is go this class
tomorrow yeah and you're going to get a
full ride to florida state and then be
like next day and show a picture of an
empty seat you're like [ __ ] i don't know
how do you not get yours wake up like
wake up yeah but then this is so
frustrating because it'll be like that
like they'll show somebody [ __ ] up
like that you're like this [ __ ] idiot
and then they're like here's his
backstory and you're like sorry i called
that guy an idiot
his like mom shot his dad or something
like it's all really yeah oh so this was
about a high school no this is juco
first one is east mississippi you know
that coat that coach got canceled
because uh he of course punched a ref in
the first season
he got canceled because there's one
there's a german kid on the team and the
german kid uh outed his dms
because he dm the kid this guy's a
[ __ ] idiot great but an idiot yeah he
did he dm the kid goes i'm your hitler
yeah you said i'll be your handler
hitler no german kid
no
yeah no these coaches are the funniest
did you get fired for that yeah
clumsy it's a clumsy analogy
have your i love this yeah yeah yeah
yeah jason brown i think it is theo had
him on the show that's the guy from
compton yes
from compton so he came out with this
whisky called slap dick whiskey and then
something happened he was bragging about
selling like whatever like 60 bottles or
something like that and then he said
some derogatory term like someone would
like he was telling this like store to
buy his whiskey and they're like we're
good he's like you [ __ ] to drop some
crazy language what and so
everyone just dropped them like his
wisdom got cancelled but he was he
seemed happy he seemed happy with his
life like he he was go he was in
independence kansas and he would like
the camera would come back he had like a
hot tub uh-huh and he would just sit
there and smoke a cigar
man
i remember that guy before games what's
his name brendan uh jason brown yeah he
would give like pep talks to his team be
like yo i'm from compton and all those
players were like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about oh this is the dude yeah
he rules right here
yeah yeah that's him and he played ball
he was good i think when he was a high
school ball player i think a big
[ __ ] yeah he's big yeah i think
he holy [ __ ] he played quarterback yeah
he played quarterbacks
at school yeah but he was so passionate
and funny man does he have a career
announcement was he was he did he act
like he was hood oh yeah oh yeah
the way he would talk to the kids yeah
it was crazy yeah that's why he had a
swagger to him
yeah but like
you know i'm not like oh he talks like a
black guy from the 90s yeah oh okay so
it was a little like so true it was kind
of sucks yeah this whole team was like
yeah they really didn't relate to it
it was like awkward as [ __ ] yeah just
old lingo
yeah yeah
he was like come in with like fubu
jerseys and [ __ ] no he's just like he's
wild yeah he's wild you guys
he was a good coach but he was just like
very loosey-goosey yeah they're all
loosey-goosey for like those kids you
need discipline so they can move on oh
we gotta go like but those kids like i
would be like man you ain't balling out
yeah you ain't balling out you ain't
[ __ ] you're like you just kicked guys
off the table you're back on the next
day like you're back on no consistency
it was just crazy yeah but it was for tv
it was fantastic my favorite one was i
think it was independence where they
were like
they were playing
like a southern iowa
some juco from iowa and they're like
we're gonna [ __ ] kill these white
dudes
just 50 white dudes show up and just
pound it down their throat
just power eye
yeah but they're all like throwing their
helmets they're like [ __ ] this [ __ ] it
was just one even though
it's just white guys that white coach
you let these white boys do this to you
what the [ __ ] yeah they're like
disciplined i gotta i gotta watch this
one of the games it's like their second
uh yeah i think it's the second game of
the season they just straight up clear
the bench in a fist fight yeah with the
other team and he gets suspended for
like four years that's why he missed the
point
yeah it's fantastic
i got to watch this one dealing with
self-destructive behavior like that
that's like that's sabotage
that's why the coaches are there yeah
you realize that that's why it's great
everybody hates themselves to a degree
that they're gonna [ __ ] it up
you realize that like jason brown any of
those guys there's so much self-loathing
that you can get them right to the
[ __ ] edge and you go all you gotta do
is jump bro and just sprout wings just
jump all you gotta do is do something
and they'll just be like damn they'll
fall over because they just don't
believe the
the the like kind of the secret sauce of
the show was the lady who would help the
kids in class she was like so good i
just got a fight with my friend about
this what i thought she was flirting
with those kids a little oh oh she
definitely my friend was like no 100 she
loves them no no no dude look how
they're behaving yeah like if i was
dating that lady and then saw that show
when it came out
what the [ __ ] like that big tackle did
you jack him up no i don't i don't agree
i i think she was she was long suffering
and loved them
i think she loved them
i'm just saying from my own insecurity
like if she was posting pictures with
like if you want to ask me every day i'd
be like is she hot yeah
yeah she was hot she was cool in the
she's a little too into the kids she
feel me and she breaks some of the
relationships with the kids
yeah
i don't mean i thought you were talking
about the black woman who is no this
lady okay the teacher okay yeah let's
see oh she's like a podcast oh
look at her and then i go uh you know go
back to that one right there bottom i
might be on your team
like you can hang out with them just
don't take pictures with them all right
[Applause]
she's kind of sexy look at that look at
that sexy yeah she's kind of hot now
it's hot it's a real shame if she does
just do this for you know i think she
does obviously i love the game she loves
them then i also think she likes big
dick
there's also there's a channel you can
have both you can't oh god
no she's gorgeous and maybe she
harnessed her love for big dick for good
yeah by helping these yeah either way
these kids will listen to her and [ __ ]
she she would like if they were gonna
miss the class then if they miss one
more they get kicked out of school yeah
she'd go to their dorm which was like
the worst living conditions ever she'd
go to their dorms and like knock on
their door and get them to class really
she she had the toughest job in the
world she's she yes she's an agent she
really cares she's an angel okay
but we're being disrespected if i was
those dudes i'd be
whacking off the her constantly yes is
that her
leg up there
no no that's not her
that was not her
red flag
[Laughter]
that is not her i don't know hold on let
me see she's on book out no all right no
she was great though then the the the
newest season look at that picture yeah
the new season's that was really the
only one that cared yeah everyone else
like
[ __ ] them get them off the team she was
the one person that was like
these kids need help
this one yeah look at that
it's nice it's a nice picture man
nice
she looks like um i don't i don't think
she was hooking up with him now that i
think about it no you don't think one
thing one slip through you haven't seen
it you gotta watch it with this d tackle
yeah even even i told my grandma yo
she's [ __ ] him
like she's too handsy yeah she's like
she's like you got that d man that's so
cool and he's like oh thank you
yeah you got that
she's like sitting on their laps and
stuff
she does oh yeah it's
all right then yeah i think that might
be a lie no i'm telling that part that
part might she sits on their lap there's
there's video on there i think that
probably might that's probably made up
she can't sit on their lap i'm telling
you i don't recall hold on
i'm i'm telling you they say i'm there
i'm i don't know you she's his other lab
that's wild i'm almost positive
[Music]
i like your attitude i like what you're
saying but that's not true and that's
okay we'll see
uh
because the chance of any of them going
anywhere basketball yeah starting now
yeah yeah and the the poor coach man
he's like they're like
he has like six kids he's awesome he
does it like you know yeah he gets fired
up i watch that rinse around he doesn't
swear yeah he's the best of the coaches
by far the best he's probably the best
and then there was a guy
a job with the uh with usc and the
lakers and turned it down really he said
i'm trying to give back to the kids yeah
that guy's awesome his wife's like [ __ ]
yeah
bloody the big fat guy in season one
he's a dick
and then the guy from compton
those two are those ones dude they
if their team is losing they explode
they're down like seven nothing at the
beginning of game and they'll be like
[ __ ] it get the [ __ ] out like just
spazzing on coordinators if someone
throws the interception it's just like
game over here
even if they're up 14 they throw
interceptions and it's like they have no
momentum and all these players don't
want to be there because they're all
just trying to go d1 yeah but they're
all just like it's in the middle of
cambodia they're just like a nightmare
and some kids like there was a big shot
that was that florida state like a
five-star recruit yeah it didn't work
out for you sock the lady in the face
what yeah they're wild i will say this
yeah i'm not going to defend him but
watch the tape yeah
every story has two sides that's all i'm
going to say she did wait there's a tape
of it out there yeah oh yeah
what did she do
it looked to me like she did try to hit
him or swung at him yeah they're like
i'm not saying he should punch a lady in
the face yeah that's [ __ ] outrageous
this is at florida state yeah i got
kicked out and had to go to independence
yeah he had to go okay wait did she did
he fought did she follow him no they
they're at a bar
they're at a bar he's like a freshman
yeah they bump into each other at the
bar right and she like nudges him out of
the way to get in the spot of the bar
and he's like what are you doing and i
think she kind of swings at him and then
he just
oh holy [ __ ] he's not good he reacted
it's very bad very bad but there's don't
hit women yeah yeah but
floor stays like you can't have it man
yeah damn so that's why he had to go to
the with the compton coach yeah and then
he's like real cocky when he gets there
you know he's like throwing bombs
my friend my friend doesn't work out
yeah
i don't think he cared i think he went
out
and then yeah and the coach was like
doing a play like nah [ __ ] that yeah
he's like you don't know anything oh for
real the kid was like i went to florida
state you're no
and his dad was like i think in the nfl
too so he thought he knew more than the
coaches yeah it was like the perfect
[ __ ] storm but it's must-see tv yeah
it's the best i gotta yeah i gotta watch
this season
you can't hit oh it's selfish of course
you can't
hey kiddos a lot of y'all got them crazy
student loans and with today's low
interest rates it's a great time to
refinance your student loans with
earnest earnest offers low rate student
loan refinancing and you can check your
rate risk-free in just two freaking
minutes with earnest you get flexible
payments you can pick your loan term all
right by refinancing you can reduce your
loan terms save money combine multiple
loans this is one simple monthly payment
if you have any questions you can talk
to a real human at earnest for help
isn't it time you stop feeling
overwhelmed by your student debt any
time aren't you sick of it earnest is
offering you guys a hundred dollar cash
bonus refinance your student debt at
earnest.com fighter terms condition
supply all right ernest is giving you
guys a hundred dollar bonus refinance
your student loans at earnest.com
fighter terms condition supply once
again 100 buck cash bonus when you visit
earnest.com fighter to refinance your
student loan not available in all states
term conditions apply this episode of
finding the kid with shane gillis is
brought to you by the best supplements
on the god damn planet i'm talking about
on it supplements whatever your goal is
in fitness you're going to need some
supplements but you can't trust all
supplements you get if you want you can
be thick but be healthy thick and in
order to get there you need to trust
your supplements that's why i mess with
on it for years and years and years i've
spewed to you guys audit supplements on
it this on it that it's because they're
the best
proof is in the supplements you need
protein powder creatine glutamine shroom
tech total gut health all right new mood
alpha brain you can get alpha brand
whole foods now for god's sakes we got a
keto collection we got nutrition for you
man we got coffee whey protein
plant-based protein protein bars protein
bites elk bars warrior bars my favorite
mct oil for you real keto kids out there
we have fitness gear
we have freaking on-demand streaming
workouts home fitness programs there's
no reason not to get in shape in 2021
man come on step your game up let onit
help you on it.com fighter 10 off the
entire goddamn site on it.com fighter 10
off well my buddy my buddy's at a bar
and he's dating a girl breaks they have
a fight they kind of break up they're
not dating that you know and she goes
just right there at the bar she's
leaving no they're talking
you know he is she goes whack open hand
whack so she comes
this way
comes back
and then goes to smack him again so he
goes
boom really hard
knuckles
as the thing coming he just goes like he
goes hey
and hits her like that she goes
like that yeah and the bartender goes
hey like that and the bartender comes
over you got to get out of here and the
bar and my body goes my buddy goes
she just paint brushed me
and she was coming back for a snap shot
and he goes i saw everything i saw the
whole [ __ ] thing dude i can't witness
i still gotta get you get [ __ ] yeah
you gotta you know so they both had to
leave but that was it she [ __ ] whack
whack he just gave her one he's like
you're not coming back a third time i
gave you two yeah yeah i mean how many
times do i have to until i i gotta
defend myself i mean you might want to
that's the move though you gotta just
yeah he said he goes
to state quarterback he doesn't hit
bartenders have a weird arrogance don't
they i don't like them i don't like them
either i don't like but hipster
bartenders like they have this weird
arrogance like you don't own the bar
yeah yeah my [ __ ] dream but they can
they do have you by the balls a little
bit because if it's crowded you just
want to get a drink for you and your
girl yeah yeah and now you got to play
you know
yeah they see if you raise your hand
which is i guess a dick move you go like
what you but if you're not paying
attention unless you're a hot chick with
big tit they don't pay attention so
you're like yo dude and then i always go
what whiskeys you have they're like
all right [ __ ] you man how about that
right yeah you don't own the place they
get mad i ask for bud light
i go to cities i'm like
if i'm in a cool bar i'm like you guys
have any blood like that
they get mad yeah they kind of like we
have a pilsner they they haven't oh
cause they have they never have them
i'm the guy who asks for that for a
pilsner and if they say corona or stella
i go it's okay i want i want you to
design it you're the real deal and i'm
almost that way whiskey now now i've
you have any died whiskey you have
buffalo trays most of them have buffalo
trays that's usually the goats you have
cauliflower ears though i tend to be
true that's a real like i'm not gonna
disagree with you what do you mean
cauliflowers yeah i'm not gonna bother
you yeah yeah they also he's a giant
yeah i'm sure i just asked for wild
turkey straight up
everywhere has that yeah
and then you go scream and cry
everyone was mean
my childhood my childhood oh that's
great why do you have a [ __ ] journal
i was just i'm on the road every morning
i you know because i wake up early and i
can't sleep in so i'll wake up no matter
what six and when i go down and make
coffee where we're at in the airbnb
whatever city he's up before me just
tonight brendan
it's really nice yeah it's just amazing
man or is it is there some aggressive
stuff
yeah it's just i mean i put everything
in there my [ __ ] crazy thoughts my
happiness your favorite whatever is it
very very emotional yeah and keep that
it's a beautiful thing yeah oh yeah
never change you were like you're just
so you're so quiet sometimes i'm like
because i let everything out and if you
ever write is there any death threats on
me in that journal i was like no
yo [ __ ] brendan
that's a good thing it means you're an
original like yeah
well as you say you marched your own
drum and you haven't been as influenced
by the things that could have molded you
you just yeah you're just you know what
you are you're really hard to find yeah
i mean
good luck like you could do your
material in front of anybody nobody can
steal it yeah yeah
yeah a
[ __ ] male cheerleader who grew up
with a adopted by a white family who
likes counting crows you know i love
counting crows yeah i mean i don't know
what he's doing it's pretty good [ __ ]
what a great thing you know i know him
you do know him very well are you
serious i spent i spent like uh i made
fun of brian i just i was just with him
in two weeks because of it i was just
with him in england i spent really a
week with him yeah [ __ ] amazing and
you know
it's pretty wild he's a hell of a guy
we'll tell him i said hi i will
well is that weird
in fact he just texted me he's gonna be
like you okay yeah yeah he just texted
me is he still making music oh yeah dude
yeah his song i mean so he writes in my
buddies joey's uh farm he goes up there
and just writes alone oh really you
still have dreads no no he shaved
not too long ago yeah that's right yeah
he talked about uh the disorder that he
had he's a great dude what is that
disorder [ __ ] no russian or whatever
some would [ __ ] multiple
people
personally
was it bipolar i don't know but by the
way he's a great dude yeah that's an
amazing guy and he's so [ __ ] talented
what's his name again
uh i would be autism if he's counting
crows
i'll take this
like rain man
yeah he's great that's good stuff no but
uh yeah a journal because he's like
yeah he is jewish
yeah i think he's been gotta get rid of
this he got rid of those he could time
kids yeah he had him he had him for a
while he was going strong with those
he can he's a he can hey so he suffers
from disassociative mental health
disorder what the [ __ ] is that that's
what i yeah you wouldn't know it getting
if you know him it's like he's just
funny as [ __ ] and great and really cool
brian you know disorders you know what
that is no you can't if you if you go i
know him and i've never seen any you've
never seen like that you know that he's
just just just just so just disorders
that involve experience of dysfunction
lack of continuity between thoughts
memory surroundings actions sounds like
an identity finish a lot of songs
let's come back to it yeah that's all
that is yeah i don't know what that is
in the middle of the song what the hell
am i doing right here now no puzzles for
that game
nowadays by the way you know
mental disorders are our big business i
mean your kid has anything and you can
send them to five different experts if
you have the money if you want you could
surround your child with 15 different
yeah you can really [ __ ] wait
money can really [ __ ] your kid up
because they'll they'll they'll label
them and that's when the schools have
all the specialists
in santa monica in malibu in those
places where there's that much money
popping adderall on kids oh dude but
it's also like oh they're working
are they still doing that just oh yeah
like i know there's disorders out there
i get all that but when we were kids
it's like he's [ __ ] you know sad get
out of it dude well it's also it's also
that they have his eyeliner they have
pathologies
eyeliner and jinkos get over it dude but
they've also pathologized uh uh
aggression and natural rambunctious boy
boy stuff so boys boys relate to each
other and they rough house a lot of boys
just rough house they run into each
other boys are boys yeah boys and boys
that is considered a pathology a lot of
times that's that la school [ __ ] no not
where i'm at i know man
you gotta get out of
he passed away huh yeah i didn't know
he's dealing with cancer no no one did
i remember last time i saw him i was
like god he looks like he just
yeah
well
he was talking to me literally for 30
minutes about gambling and i was like
yeah no doubt i'm not you know i gamble
but [ __ ] dude
nearly a decade dude this is that round
he's doing it for
oh [ __ ] nine years right he didn't want
people to feel sorry for him so he
didn't he didn't tell anybody he was
saying respect legend well you were that
was we hung out with him at the comedy
story
that's where you're talking about
gambling all the time yeah he loved to
gamble he's such a talent dude
yeah
yeah he was he was one of the first
comics i saw though i was like
face hurt the whole show yeah he came
out he did a show at helium in philly
and he was like i wish i would have had
that ham sandwich earlier
anyway
didn't stand up and then throughout the
set he'd be like ah
could have had that hand
occasionally during his set
it was incredible marty lang told me a
story about him where um
he said uh he gets a call this is like
98 or something you know and he goes hey
what are you doing all right he goes i
don't know i guess i'm going to come
over and show you something
and so are just like all right so he
just comes over and he goes you want to
see what a hundred thousand dollars in
cash looks like
right there and already goes what are
you going to do with that he goes i'm
going to give it to my bookie because i
lost it
that's how that's that's right they said
he would get his money from saturday
live and drive straight to lennon city
yes [ __ ] just the best yeah the best
[ __ ] man that one yeah that made me sad
it was the first thing that was the
first uh celebrity death that uh made
you sad maybe yeah i mean i talked to
him kobe didn't he's from philly kobe
kobe was made it was weird for me i just
remember being like oh [ __ ] kobe dead it
was not like i wasn't like really
were you not a kobe fan i like i
i liked it i respected him
i liked i liked i was a big shaq yeah
oh okay there's two teams yeah
i'm a shaq diesel fan i love diesel dude
the big area you're such a freak that's
another that's another combo like you
everybody would have thought our uh arty
would have died before norm you would
have guessed shaq would have gone before
kobe jack's like a [ __ ] saint bernard
he's like seven he's gonna die soon
that's not the best thing to say about
what i mean no but yeah he's like just
huge [ __ ] he's enormous and he's tons of
papa john's pizza yeah he said he says
his foot size 20 22 or something like
that
it's
have you ever seen you ever see him in
blue chips that movie with nick nolte
yeah you see what kind of an athlete
you're scared try to bring up well dude
it's skinny but like dunking and moving
like where you're like are you talking
about the biggest freaks oh dude that
movie took you realized that he was well
because i he was so big to see how
athletic he was
nick nolte yeah he's never saw him play
at lsu
watch him duncan
he's a freak yeah
are his kids pretty big look at him
there yeah one place for ucla he had to
have open heart surgery
yeah
yeah yeah
any harder way was in that
yeah that movie's awesome no shaq was
such a [ __ ] freak there's nobody like
him he was unstoppable dude unstoppable
that was the team dude magical
when i was a kid that was the coolest
team ever i can that was my favorite
team yeah because they were awesome
growing up it was penny uh darren scott
they called him 3d there's the white boy
who i loved uh
what was it yeah scout scott skyles
he turned into a coach
but shaq was a [ __ ] dude we could run
the court he's seven foot tall dunk i
mean beast dude i didn't see i didn't
watch college basketball then i'm
watching that movie on watch blue chest
this guy is jumping up and this guy's
going to get real this guy's got
something oh my god
you know i realized michael jordan was
good when i saw
without space in front of them so you
watch them and i'm like jesus
you got to watch him play some [ __ ]
ball
how about when i was did you collect
cards as a kid yeah when i was a kid i i
got this uh i forgot what
company it was but i bought the pack of
cards and it was shaq's rookie here
remember shaq i think was number two and
christian leighton was number one and
those were like the cards like
everyone's trying to get these cards and
our mom didn't have a lot of money and
she's like you guys can get a pack each
and so i was young dude was that 90. so
i was seven or eight and i remember open
the pack i'm you know you're going
through like come on come on
boom christian latener which was like
the number one card to have right behind
that shaquille o'neal and my brother had
anger management issues like you know he
didn't get anything so he beat me up and
then
later on this kind of brother i was late
that night i was like you can have one
pick one i'll keep one you keep one yeah
wow who did he take shaq because ah good
picture
good luck with that yeah i'll take
christian or late night loser is that
the dude that hated that duke yeah yeah
yeah everyone likes a great player in
college yeah yeah decent in the nba just
got a bad rap oh got it yeah he was just
people just hated him yeah people hate
dude because he was just good
um he had this arrogance about him like
he oh he was a [ __ ] yeah he's a bit
of an ass
yeah he talks about it he looks like
that there's a great thirty-four thing
oh he looked like the dudes in the nba
are like [ __ ] this guy
yeah but you if you look back on his
career he wasn't
bad in them did they hate reddick
yeah j.j reddick yeah at first yeah but
they're in the nba he's kind of like
he's all liked he's solid yeah oh wait
that one kid grayson allen is he from
duke yes oh okay who's that kid who's
that guy there was this show where they
were talking about he was kind of not a
good nba player white dude he was not
good i mean he was that they were always
talking about but he played for like
nine ten years or whatever and
they're all talking about how much he
sucked and he goes here's the thing i do
suck but not compared to you oh and then
he talked about scalabrine the redhead i
think whoever was he called out all that
kid calling him out that was he called
out the team did you see him play
one-on-one d1 players
[ __ ] all over smoking d1 players doing
whatever you want like real play it
happens in fighting too like because of
the celebrity boxing and you know the
logan paul stuff where average joes are
like that guy's not that [ __ ] tough
like a real fighter yeah like machine
gun kelly with connor it's like dude you
have any idea what would happen so
yeah they almost got like a fighter
argument yeah he's like six five
whatever like talented musician but it's
like the lines are blurred but it's like
with the nba it's even more blurred like
have you ever
ever
seen an nba player like in the gym like
playing regular pickup basketball yeah
like like like bert you remember birdman
yeah nick nick anderson was it uh nick
anderson i forget his name the guy who
played for the nuggets yeah i'm hanging
out with him a couple times me too yeah
he's awesome good buddy yeah so when he
was playing for denver he was like oh
let's go play uh pickup at uh greenwood
athletic club which was like my home
club so me and my brother grew up there
and i was like i guess i was talking to
my brother i'm like i guess we just
throw him like ali oops and [ __ ] he's
just gonna dunk on everybody we're gonna
dominate yeah and uh my brother's like
yeah so i'll stay like they had a whole
plan i was like i'll just like throwing
balls and like [ __ ] dunk on everybody
and it's gonna be lit as [ __ ] dude
he was like what no just give me the
ball he didn't miss a single shot like
he was shooting like steph curry and
you're like oh oh my god nope like we
didn't make it take it yeah yeah yeah
nobody else touched the ball he was
literally just like you're in the mba
slap yeah
like for sure just dunk it dude god and
then kids would try to like shoot over
me just like what the [ __ ] just
i mean no yeah yeah yeah you don't want
to fight conor mcgregor if you're
machine gun kelly i'd be a very bad
teacher but the lines are blurred was he
trying to was he getting up in his team
was but they they said it all uh came
from
a it might be a publicity stunt but b
you i guess connor dm'd uh his girl back
in the day and so i guess machine gun
because he won a picture and machine gun
kelly was like now get the [ __ ] out of
here and then connor just went off oh
[ __ ]
i can't believe somebody make up they
made odds they made odds already yeah
that can't be real
those are yeah there's actual rules
there could be there should
it's just you don't
like everybody should play uh nba player
in a pickup game just to see where you
fit yeah yeah yeah or or just roll like
one like
i know well i know you can say be like
oh connor's not a black belt very cool
roll with conor mcgregor let me know how
it goes for you yeah yeah yeah go ahead
see what i get his i know he's not
[ __ ] he's hurt
or damien maya just roll with him let me
get him for you yeah and then you want
to then you want to fight the guy in
what stand up yeah it's nuts actually
this is another one go try if you if
you're a tough guy and you can you've
done some fighting you can sit down
don't try to hit yeah
yeah will you put a compilation of
downhill skiing or accidents
i genuinely i watch these they're
[ __ ] wise
dude they get so [ __ ] up oh my god no
but i was saying try just try touching
try hitting putting your glove on a guy
who can actually box who knows how to
move out of the way yeah but now you're
talking about conor mcgregor literally
one of the best striking artists we've
ever seen
in in our entire life dude and machine
kelly you play a guitar and you have
jewels on your jaw listen you're gonna
hit him no no it's not no no
bad idea but who knows maybe machine gun
kelly was like chilling
just a psycho yeah like [ __ ] you yeah
yeah
well he did uh connor threw a beer at
him
kelly does look like he's going like
this
yeah
can be rough yeah like you like you're
the funny guy at the family barbecue
very cool go do a philly crowd on a
friday night when they've been working
all day and drinking and or go to
pittsburgh where it's blue collar and
they've been drinking all day yeah you
got to get this rogan used to say that
don't do that yeah stand up is the one
thing that everyone thinks they can do
oh everybody that's like everybody
pretty funny yeah but right give it a
shot
about we and i went to a club one time
and there were these alt comics and all
due respect there are some really funny
all comics but these guys were it was
when it first came started coming out
where they were doing like that esoteric
stuff yeah real meta kind of making
anti-funny yeah
and rogan was like this rogan was
watching this guy you know brogan he's
just like this is [ __ ] death
and so uh when he was younger he was
like like whatever you think is aggro
double it like he just did not give a
[ __ ] because now the weed chills amount
oh but before that never smoked weed
yeah no no he was just before that he
was like your grandpa ct
oh god all the time
no matter what he said that he goes you
bring that [ __ ] to philly you bring that
[ __ ] to jersey to boston
pittsburgh where people work for a
living and they're like i gotta be in a
factory at [ __ ] six in the morning
make me laugh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i spent money on what is this yeah yeah
what is this that you're doing here
yeah that's i mean that's how it starts
though with stand up everybody that like
you think you're funny
i'll give it a shot i mean that's what i
did yeah and i got up there and i
blacked out
yeah no i'm sober i don't remember you
i'm terrified i was so in a dude i was
holding the mic was it just an open mic
at my like belly button was it an open
mic yeah it's just an open mic in philly
in harrisburg you know who can get away
with comedy you know get away with [ __ ]
like who would just do weird [ __ ] with
uh nick uh schwartzen nick even when he
was young
like that's like you know the ham
sandwich thing nick one time me and my
question nick and nick is doing stand-up
and it's not he's trying weird [ __ ] and
it's at the comic strip in new york and
this is like [ __ ] 2000 or earlier or
whatever and he's like he's like nothing
it's not really working he's like hey
guys he goes
i apologize i just i hate a lot of
turkey
um before this and turkey makes you
super tired so i don't feel like i
haven't said it
sorry
so i'm watching this out
and he could tell another joke and he'd
be like yeah and then people would kind
of laugh and go [ __ ] turkey
eating turkey all the time
and he kept doubling down that turkey by
the end of it i was [ __ ] crying
that's like theo hope you know at the
store wherever when he opened for me in
uh nashville he's like i just don't feel
[ __ ] funny man i'm trying new [ __ ]
and he goes out there and he'll be like
yeah my my cousin got bit in l.a he got
bit man by
man so funny he's so unique did you know
uh rogan at all before you did the pod
no i just hung out with him that week
leading up to it because i was in austin
doing shows
at uh i recorded my special in did you
yeah yeah
yeah have you done the vulcan yet i did
it's a slipknot concert yeah yeah it's a
little there's like metal and people
standing up
have you done a vulcan yet no it's good
it's good it's good if for for like if
you walked in there and saw that room
you'd be like this is going to be a
[ __ ] disaster because it's a rock
room it's like it's made for it's like
music it's a music for like tall
ceilings so it's like there's like yeah
literally that was my joke i was like
feeling that i was like i feel like i'm
in a [ __ ] slipknot concert like
there's like metal everywhere that's
tough it's in but people are standing
and there's couches yeah and then after
we were performing it turns into like a
rave show like goes on yeah like people
are waiting to get in the door to
[ __ ] do drugs and
lick each other's ass that's weird wow
yeah but yeah they've it's a good club
though they did make it good like it
shouldn't be what about where it
shouldn't work so the creek in the cave
is uh what is that is that a comedy club
yeah it was in new york
no i just moved to new york
and like i just got in at the seller
so there's no reason to i'm gonna stay
at the seller yeah the seller is really
good yeah oh yeah yeah
it's it's dude it's so good i just did
buffalo with dove david off and the
stand by the way yeah shout out to the
stuff
too yeah
yeah yeah he's around it's it's great
and it's just like
it's hard to bomb did you get very hard
did you get passed on the first try
first uh i had a weird
way of getting past because i auditioned
like kind of before covet and then covet
happened so i actually auditioned like
before snl a little bit and then i got
canceled
and they're like
and then i got and then covet happened
so there was like really no window for
me to even audition and then uh they
just called and were like send us your
veils
out of nowhere you've probably talked
about this before who called you to tell
you you weren't on snl uh
lauren and like a man like a lady and
then lauren
like a lady that represents like any
time you talk to lauren somebody would
call him be like michael's on the line
was he cool i like i like learn a lot
yeah i still do was it your i'm sure
again i'm sure you've talked about this
that's fine
was it your dream to do saturday live
like was that maybe in like seventh
grade when it was but then once i
started doing stand-up i was like this
is
yeah i knew i i figured i would never be
on snl
like ever because i've seen it yeah yeah
lately and i know what i do yeah you
know
yeah it's fair you think it's a blessing
in disguise that all this happens sure
you guys here's what i said what else
you gonna do though you know what i'm
saying like you yeah
you could sulk on it and of course
that's yeah what could you do should i
quit but but i i gotta be honest it's
one of the reasons i think
a lot of people rallied around because
everyone's like definitely the [ __ ]
we've all said stupid [ __ ] yeah you know
but there's also like uh
like there's i think if i would have got
snl i think i could have done very well
on it i agree you had a good career that
way 100 and now that i got cancelled
from it or however you want to say it
yeah uh
i think that i that is also a good
opportunity so i would say
i would rather it have happened
than not at all you know what i mean
yeah you know like if i just never got
snl and never got either way i think
it's put you on them yeah yeah for sure
yeah and i think
uh
yeah i'm alright i'm comfortable having
eyes on
me
with my what i'm creating well you're
creating you're like i'm not afraid to
i'm not worried about a spotlight on
what i make
no but that makes sense no it makes
sense if i sock thing got canceled that
would be a tough huge problem well you
want to have a career yeah that would be
a major issue but i i think too it's
like you know the fans that rallied
around you and then
they brought all this attention to you
those are the people that [ __ ] with you
like those are your actual fans
instead of like life they're not all
shane gillis fans sure now you're
building a real fan base there's a
downside
there's a doubt but you're also playing
like when you're on the road now you're
playing home games sure you get your
fans you can [ __ ] around like you're
special
you know if you're just a life fan you
turn into let's say you're on there and
you turn and you're stressed like jesus
christ shane went hard in the pain yeah
your fans are like [ __ ] yeah that would
have been a pain you know what i'm
saying but it was all it's also there is
downside that like immediately when you
get canceled there are a lot of people
that you don't want as a fan yeah
oh yeah i gotta have guys coming up to
me after shows and like screaming slurs
yeah i'd be like hell yeah be like i
don't think you get it yeah
thank
you that shirt off yeah i think if
you're gonna do that
yeah i think people rallied around you
because
most people are not comfortable and
shouldn't be with the idea that you said
something in passing
in a certain context
like in a conversation
and your whole life should not be
erased for that sure your opportunity
which is a huge one in snl which very
few people get shouldn't be taken away
yeah and that is the world yeah and i
think everyone would agree including
myself that it wasn't great
yeah my what i said yeah yeah but uh
yeah i think the punishment didn't
really match the crime right i agree and
that's where everyone was like all right
maybe chill
but and i also think the other yeah i
think that's the counter to council
culture it's like all right he said
something should have said
he lost his job and i think most humans
are like nah that ain't right man well
because you know they're tuned in right
and the other thing that's really
important to realize that when you do
cancel somebody like when they do that
to you
you're not making the world more
equitable you're actually not doing
anything you it's not as though now
you're making the world
more fair and more equal you're just
you're just kind of you're suppressing
it form of destruction you're
suppressing it making it worse yeah
i think the only real way to beat
whatever this is the cancel culture
thing is to just keep going yeah like
don't let it consume you like if i if i
got cancer and then spent the next two
years being like [ __ ] cancel culture
[ __ ] this i'm gonna stop riding then i'm
not doing it then i'm not doing that's
how that that's how you go downhill
that's how you get cancer yeah i agree
you let that keep moving you keep
running i think you releasing the
special was kind of like yeah definitely
not canceled you know what you're saying
although anybody could have put a
youtube special out there
but that's right
that's right anybody can put it and have
it do a good job being good and other
people co-sign it and be like hey watch
this [ __ ] special man that's the
difference yeah
and i think
you put on youtube and then
other comics in the space everyone go
dude this thing's [ __ ] good and i can
send a link to my dad or to my brother
my group i was like here's the special
if it's on netflix or it's on you know
wherever yeah showtime i can't send you
a [ __ ] link yeah like if you can clip
it up and i can send you a clip like
in this day and age that we're in like
clips or what cell takes 50 percent like
your hour like we know for a fact
even on netflix with eddie murphy or joe
rogan people stop watching after 28
minutes yeah 28 we're still 20 minutes
so we're still doing hours which is
whatever
but if you have a clip yeah you don't
need that and if you do like i was
talking to chappelle on the way i was
like just do just put a youth like if
you have 45 or a ha you don't even have
to do an hour like mine's like 48
you don't it doesn't have to be an hour
you can put out 30 minutes like i was
thinking in a year just put out another
half hour
or something yeah just keep going
whatever
half hour without [ __ ] 20 minutes
yeah you literally can do whatever you
want yeah the day and age of you know
hbo and showtime being like well only
these five guys get special this year
it's like why are you waiting on those
people yeah yeah let's put it out if
it's good especially if you write faster
if you have a lot to say you can just
put it yeah i don't
i got about four minutes right now
four minutes that's the scariest thing
yeah you gotta hide i know i was gonna
ask you that i was like oh so you
probably got another hour now
uh it's just live and awesome yeah hell
yeah i couldn't i could it doesn't
matter yeah
everybody was like you should name it
something like that i can't yeah just
live i like i like the uh the drake how
you took the draco oh yeah yeah i like
that somebody this promotion somebody
made that oh that was solid
and retweeted it oh yeah i would have
never promoted it i didn't promote it
all uh my friend john mckeever and the
guy homeless pimp
i know oh yeah
yeah i love homeless yeah he's awesome
homeless that's amazing yeah that was
guys it was just christie
about homeless pimp so homeless pimp is
christy he's on the road with him he
shoots everything produces podcasts
and chris uh
you know he has his smoke show wife and
she's pregnant and she has a smoke show
friend and she's like yeah you gotta
hook me up uh with homeless pimp and
chrissy's like
oh you sure she's like [ __ ] yeah man
that guy like he's my exact type i'm
looking for you know chris is like
yeah kristy d's like okay we'll text him
right now and then he texts him he goes
yeah he's into it so let me know what
you want to do and she's like oh i can't
wait and then she sent a picture of me
she thought i was the homeless person
oh
you're just like uh that's not the
homeless pen
gosh that's [ __ ] hilarious yeah
oh jesus christ
no yeah he rules
wrong guy homeless pimp's great who's
that guy yeah como spence the beast
who's that who's who is he's a he's a
model that i follow him his tattoos i'm
gonna follow him you guys love dude dude
we do you guys love no he's a gay man
you guys love like strong men yeah who
the [ __ ] doesn't like that guy me this
guy seems awful
i wouldn't follow him yeah i wouldn't
have bought it i just i don't mean the
description of the guy
but once you've seen it once you've seen
who is elijah i'm all over it
he was like a skinny dude at first and
he started getting jacks yeah dude yeah
steroids um
there you go who else used your cough
dude
besides uh it's where did you follow
male model though no i follow k-pop
stars and everything k-pop makes sense
you're into music they own bottles
though i want to get a i want to get
tattoos he said he likes his tattoos
i mean i got to know exactly what i want
do you have any tattoos
one yes stick with one you're fine
you're not going to turn into it
let me see how about this how about we i
did shows in dublin we like sold all
these shows out
so we what we want to get a tattoo to
remember like me my my brother's my tour
manager so we want to get tattoos in
dublin yeah so we go to this tattoo
store in dublin i asked for somebody on
instagram this guy's like come down here
man i'm right down the street legit
tattoo artist so we go down there and uh
he's like the tattoo artist is like all
right i'm not doing any [ __ ] lucky
charms i'm not doing any four leaf
clovers that's not what the [ __ ] we do
here and i was like okay that was all
our that's kind of all of us yeah yeah
okay he's like once you get a horseshoes
for good luck we're like oh cool chin's
never had a tattoo chin goes put it on
my i went on my neck
and the guy's like no i'm not getting
your first tattoo on your [ __ ] neck
no jun's like yeah i want it right in my
[ __ ] neck and the guy's like no i'm
not doing your neck man good you're
going to regret god
i honestly really wanted it especially
at that time too one memory for from
being ireland the first time huge shows
was it was a good time a great memory
yeah
next time
tattoo good times now that i have one
he'll probably give me a neck tattoo
because i had no tattoos at all that's
why he was like i think that guy's
nipples were pierced too by the way that
guy goes that's why i draw the line yeah
that guy goes all the way looks like
he's a tongue piercing as well well that
tattoo job i mean that the whole thing
was very good got chris to be posted no
this is homeless pimps but he doesn't
put himself out there
no
that's cool go to his tagged photos
maybe he'll have a couple
uh where do you go there right there
yep
nope nope
we have no idea what homeless pimp looks
like he has a big old beard glasses
there areas yeah he looks like mankind
he looks like mankind yeah that's him
like mick foley holy [ __ ] captain jack
dude love yeah i was like you're looking
chris foley right yeah he's like who i'm
like [ __ ] the sock guy mankind so
yeah
and i think he
struggles with pronouns is that right
yeah he's like in the third round with
his pronouns is he yeah i think so
really
i think he goes both ways non-binary
okay
he didn't bring it up to me
and it doesn't seem like i don't know
yeah true he's gonna bring it up not a
lot of people can find it yeah and
they're pronounced yeah
chains
he's gonna that guy
strong beard for a guy who i mean that's
pretty masculine kind of look from what
i can tell i'm pretty sure he's just
like i call that that a guy a dude yeah
you say that's a dude just do from queen
he's as dude as it gets yeah what are we
talking about i guess his glasses might
be a little feminine i don't know just
how i i look like someone who they want
to cancel
yeah oh yeah i'm definitely a guy they
see and they're like
you know chris stefano's a good looking
kid nobody gives him enough credit oh he
gets credit he gets credit
yeah he's a good looking guy
she'll take some chris hey homeless
trump is bi right
oh bi is different than struggling with
the pronouns though
right yeah yeah yeah
there's again
no glasses d1 basketball player i doubt
it oh no
yeah d3
it's a sturdy kid he's a big star yeah
he's big yeah strong he was good at
basketball too wasn't he what did he
give him
he's really good d3 yeah he has like a
statue there or some [ __ ]
i'm serious
we gotta tear it down yes
that statue's racist yeah
what do you got for current events dude
all righty summer cats if i pull it up
right now really fast go ahead man of
course
all right well before i start i hope you
don't mind me asking but when you're on
rogan i say on rogan and then you said a
joke and it just flew by him yeah you
guys stared at each other oh that was
awesome
that was so great it was a
big swing i told him a story it wasn't
like it wasn't like the best it was
michael story yeah i was just telling
the story how like when i was getting
fired i was like i'll just go on rogan
and be bigger
so but of course i wasn't on rogan for
two years
it was just funny
he has some like how it went down with
like lauren michaels and he's like yeah
lauren was like you know we got to take
off saturday live and he goes all right
cool i'm just going [ __ ] rogan
pause pause
yeah so uh
he goes i was like i was like i'll just
go on rogan
yeah and then he goes
what nothing i thought was funny yeah
yeah
there's nothing but it wasn't it wasn't
like uh
in his defense
there wasn't like a clear joke and i
think he might have interpreted it as me
being like where were you know i mean
i think he might have been like not
reach out because what the joke was that
i was like arrogant that i was like like
oh fine i'll just i'm gonna move on to
rogan yeah yeah that's how i took that
was the joke it was like i would never
be like where the [ __ ] especially the
fact you went
i thought it was great thank god because
for real for the next five minutes i was
just in my head like what
what
like this is crazy and then uh
thankfully i brought it back up i was
like hold on we got to stop like yeah
whoever's watching this just rewind that
and watch my face yeah like i brought it
up thankfully yeah you got to bring it
up it's like you got to see what it just
had you can literally see my face melt
yeah
like this teeth showing swallow yeah
yeah he'll do that to you sometimes and
he'll just sit there and he's going and
he didn't you know he's doing he does
that podcast constantly so he's not
nervous he doesn't care yeah yeah but
for me it was like home field this is it
yeah i was just saying that we're not
recording right yeah we are oh do we
have to i don't care we can request okay
uh
but it was like uh there were two
moments in comedy where i was like oh
[ __ ] the one was snl like walking into
audition and seeing that stage oh crazy
because like leading up to it i was like
i don't give a [ __ ] who cares i'm not
gonna get it i'm not nervous at all and
then you walk in and see the main stage
and you're like
this is big and then for the same thing
with rogan like i was like
oh this is a podcast i do podcast every
day i've talked about snl a million
times different animals and then as soon
as you walk in that room i was like oh
[ __ ] this is that room it's jerry like
this is that room i've seen a thousand
times yeah
and then
yeah just [ __ ] as soon as we started
talking about snl i was i was just in my
own head because the whole time i was
like is this good am i bombing he was
like what are you talking about yeah
like you're fine yeah you're saying i
think i'm bombastic no you did good i
suck no it's funny well you know the
mistake people make is trying to get on
there and be funny yeah oh it never goes
well
it goes well
oh my god two bits right there that's
why i don't have like you do a bit
like what are you doing
oh nothing i just it's so stupid nothing
i'm a [ __ ] idiot i'm sorry
yeah that's why you know theo i think
went on at once you know theo [ __ ]
around like there's a lot of bits and
bro it's just like
not hitting yeah dude that's good and
then and then theo calls you and goes
man i know how to go he was good man but
uh sometimes he's just not down to play
i'm like no dude and he's like and then
he's like and then also bro that's the
longest i've ever talked to somebody in
my life yeah
that's a real real thing he goes i
haven't talked to my mom for three hours
that's it for real thing when was the
last time you talked to anybody for
three hours that's a long [ __ ] time
right even on five times
five times a week dude and he'll do it
with the top scientists elon like genius
people oh yeah so when the comics get in
there he's like ah [ __ ] yeah it's not as
fun you guys for three hours yeah damn
yeah and then you you know it's a bad
show if it's only like an hour and 40.
true yeah it didn't go well for you i
didn't know that so when i got done
i was like i think that might have i
think i sucked of course the whole like
then we went out to eat we're hanging
out and i'm like did i [ __ ] i was
just i must have been so [ __ ]
annoying to him like did that suck i
[ __ ] blew it didn't i and there he
was like
you're fine no it's great yeah it's
great and uh
then i did it then when it came out it
was like three hours or whatever and
someone was like oh it must have been
good if it's not if it's under like
depending what if it's under three yeah
yeah as long as it's over like two and a
half you're good but if it's under that
it's like oh you're out of [ __ ] to talk
about yeah um he's one but he's he's
like he's like our version of johnny
carson yeah you go on there especially
before i'm not saying spotify is not
like that but it's not as big but you
know
when you would go on there it was
literally like it was your audition for
like on the tonight shirt like you would
you could build a career off of that man
i never thought of it that way yeah oh
yeah i never did either now in hindsight
years and years later like some of the
fight campaigns we [ __ ]
like you know i do fight companion now
and it's more fight talk but when you me
eddie and rogan would do we talked about
octopus for an hour yeah we'd have like
seven million views i never even know i
was like who the [ __ ] would watch eddie
rant on conspiracies for an hour while
you're shouting at it right we get all
drunk and shout at eddie that's great
and shawn who's right on most things
yeah
okay yeah i think there's a special time
man it's a really special time sure yeah
i got i remember i did letterman in 1999
and i saw his mug i was backstage and
somebody said somebody made something
saying you know the beatles performed on
this stage
great gotta get you that got me and i
went
and then i saw
letterman's mug and i watched him so
much
and i was doing that triggered you it
triggered me and i went out and i got
[ __ ] almost debilitated i was so
[ __ ] nervous yeah when i say four and
a half minutes which is even worse if
you have like an hour you can yeah four
and a half years
you got to get your beak wet dude back
then you're not getting comfortable hit
the camera there then turn and do this
one if you can and then you're like
[ __ ] up the only time i've ever felt
that in stand-up is i i grew up my mom
was the biggest robin williams fan she
loved robin williams and i was playing
cobbs for the first time not with you by
myself
and my mom uh text me a picture that i
drew of robin williams and she was like
you know that was robin williams home
club literally like 20 minutes before i
went outside sweet though and then i was
like oh [ __ ] robin williams was here i
didn't think about it you know you
weren't doing club you're just going
going yeah and then when you stopped
smell the roses and i talked to the gym
like hey this was robin williams club he
was like yeah man he's here here in
punchline like oh this was his [ __ ] he
like helped us so many times i'm like
he was on that stage
he's like yeah dude i was like oh no
doubt i called my mom i was crying yeah
yeah yeah that crazy yeah
that's so weird yeah there's a couple of
the seller
that was one like walking down those
steps for the first time i did yeah the
first time i did the seller i was like
oh [ __ ] i might i never had any
reference for any comics or any comedy i
never you know
i never had one you were an actor i was
an actor and i and i didn't even have i
had representatives
whatever yeah i never had any reference
for comics
i just didn't i to me it was nev never
the mystery that say acting was or
writing
like you know if i met certain people or
sports like if you know certain guys who
were just like amazing athletes if they
were just a mystery to me i was like you
know every you know before when the
comedy store was the store like
obviously now they're going through the
transition but was a store no matter
what you know i do it a million times no
matter what i'd have to hype myself up
in the car because i know it's the kind
and remember i came up with you were
coming up you were all huge between
you're also wedged between
the biggest comics in the world oh i'd
be like hey who who who real who am i
going to play it's crazy they'd be like
oh you're between uh joey diaz and chris
deleo like
yeah here we go sebastian and bill burr
and rogan i mean that was a lineup yeah
that's crazy
you know
tuesday night to a tuesday night tuesday
night was the pop-up night that was
incredible it's like training camp
there's nothing better yeah that's a
good thing it's not it's nice it helps
like i i did uh sorry yeah you're fine
uh like i was i walked into the cellar
and louie was just standing in the hall
and they were like i was like oh [ __ ]
he's bumping me
and he was well of course he was nice
about it he was like you don't care and
i was like no and uh i was like but now
i gotta [ __ ] follow you yeah that
sucks and he's like no it's good
he's like everybody in that room is
gonna be like oh our night's made
now we're all happy so like once they
see like the the best it's actually easy
they're still they're all excited
they're happy and he was like just don't
mention it he's like don't go on because
he used to do that with like seinfeld
like he'd have to follow seinfeld and
then he would go on stage
how am i going to follow seinfeld and
the whole crowd would be like yeah
how are you going to do it's a great no
i wish somebody never mentioned it i
wish somebody gave this guy i wish i had
that note because i remember
like four years ago i had to follow neil
brennan is when his special came out and
he did some crazy bit was like you know
just the the his vocabulary he's like so
much better than mine he's such smart
dude he wrote chappelle and he like
brought the house down and i
acknowledged it i want to say i
acknowledged it and it i ate [ __ ] yeah i
thought why would i do that that was
incredible right not do that yeah it was
i would have never thought he gave me
that no yeah but
in my mind i was like i'll address it
because they know i'm not neil brennan
so i'm going to address it just so the
elephant's out of the room but they're
like what the yeah at the tommy store
you better i've had i've had to follow
like if you're here you better be good
yeah i've had to follow literally
everybody from chris rock to you yeah
you know but i know i never obviously
thought about it but
but i part of it is because i just
believed i was you know i'm fine you
have to yeah yeah but you have to rogan
made me follow uh burr
one time on rogan and friends yeah
that's good that's bro because bird
wanted to go up early and i was like oh
am i gonna go
like like before him and then burr go up
but then he was just like it's gonna go
poston
burr lacy and then rogan and i was like
all right holy [ __ ] yeah you're good you
know
the only time
that's like yeah but you need to need
that navy seals put on more you know
yeah equipment that's all you're doing
the only time i ever mentioned anything
was when i was doing gotham i was
headlining gotham and seinfeld came in
and asked me if he could you know to get
up and do some stuff before me like
basically to treat because he was doing
letterman or something i mean or he was
doing uh leno
and i was like of course you know of
course yeah and he gets up and does his
thing and the only thing i said was
after he got off i you know they brought
me on and all i said was i was like
well they asked me who i wanted to have
feature for me and uh
yeah
they were all [ __ ] happy
yeah yeah i remember the first time ever
headlined at the comedy store was the
belly room and uh i was like yeah where
are they they asked me like a two-day
notice i'm like god give me a little
heads up like no just run your whatever
hour in the in the belly room like [ __ ]
man that's a big deal and so i was like
hell yeah i'm in so i'm like why would
they call me who canceled and it was
game seven of the dodgers that night so
nobody's
showing up and there was probably seven
people in the crowd
dude seven people in the crowd i'm in
the back i felt like such a loser i'm
like oh the store's never gonna fight me
back man i'm such a [ __ ] loser and
dave chappelle walks in the back and
goes what's up youngin i'm like what's
up dave chappelle he was uh your
headline tonight ago yeah he goes you
mind if i get on before
i was like i mean
i'd really rather you didn't no i was
like
no i went i went do whatever you want to
do talk about my mouth
my mouth was so dry i remember going
whatever you want to do dude dude he
went out there he did two hours yeah
he'll do that then i went on at around
probably 1 30 when there's three people
in the game it was just like i i don't
know yeah and you know the bummer was
there's other comics on before me and
dave and in the back is like oh i'm
gonna pick his brain on comedy and like
oh i'm gonna bring up all this [ __ ] and
all he wanted to talk about was fighting
anybody who knows me knows i [ __ ]
hate that yeah unless it's like i'll
talk fighting with rogan or something
like that but it's just general
questions about fighting i was like [ __ ]
dude yeah and i could not get a word in
about comedy well he beat you to the
punch because i bet he hates talking
about you were gonna be like chappelle
show that yeah that's probably
[ __ ]
and then he was like then he was like
you know health he was like you think
this thing's bad for me and it was a
vape pen i was like it ain't good yeah
he's like yeah my doctor he's like i was
like it sounds like your doctor's full
of [ __ ] and i was like
why am i giving you [ __ ] help
i don't know dude
whatever you're doing keep doing it man
how about that what would you ask him
about comedy though i i wouldn't know i
i don't know just like you know i don't
know just another time i would have
figured out in a moment
not really much if i was teaching a
class on comedy no i'm not looking for
like hey with your joke dude but i you
know i don't i don't know like hey man
you have you done pittsburgh improv like
that like hey because when i was there
the blue collar like some stuff didn't
hit or just like i had a guy come on
why'd you get into comedy yeah
like what made you want to be i had a
producer come to me and go i have an
amazing idea for you i was like alright
you're going to teach an online stand-up
class
how many people would tune in to hear
you talk about comedy you've had all
this experience and i was like
i there is not a thing i could teach
anyone about you know what it is uh
write and do it yeah intentions get on
stage
get up get up what do you mean what am i
gonna tell you get up
it's like what can you tell me about
playing guitar i don't know you gotta
play it for a while but it's also like i
was telling chappelle this yesterday we
were talking about this comic
who i was like he's never going to make
it dude he's our friend i was like he's
never going to make it yeah because he's
lazy he doesn't write and i was like and
he's busy chasing girls and i told
chappelle i'm like he's never going to
make it because if you think about like
if because they're like say something
like if if i have to say hey dude make
sure you're getting up doing sets make
sure you're doing this you're already at
such a disadvantage you're never going
to make it because i know other comics
who are hustling their ass off who are
funnier yeah and nobody has to tell them
to do that well yeah it's because you
want to do it yeah you do it because you
you
have to want it more than anything like
like i was telling like i i made this
comparison like when i was uh in the ufc
and i i was like ranked number 10 in the
world at that time and there's a lot of
young kids in the in the gym and mark
millionaires calls me hey man
these guys you know they're trying to be
in the ufc they want to be like you can
you come down and talk to them because a
lot of them are they're missing practice
and they're just not dedicating i said
mark i'm telling you dude you don't want
me to do it he's like no i'm telling you
really maybe boost the morale like go
talk to him like tell me you don't want
me to do it man he's like no i'm telling
you whatever you do i i co-sign go do it
so he gets all the kids there and i go
how many want to go to ufc and they
raise their hand cool
now mark tells me you guys have trouble
showing up to practice
none of you are going to make it yeah no
all you that raise your hand none of you
will make yeah i promise you i you know
how many times a coach had to tell me to
come to practice zero they go how may i
go
[ __ ] never get to take the keys from
me from the gym because they couldn't
get me out of there yeah and that's what
you're dealing with and there's a
hundred other guys just like me yeah
that are [ __ ] chomping at the dick to
make three years
you know it's chomping at the pit right
yeah
what
[Applause]
i got shadow band and he spelled it
b-a-n-d oh man
yeah and i was like shadow band
band no he felt like a rubber band
and i was like and he had this whole
thing oh baby good dudes could do this i
was like god damn it there's nothing
wrong with somebody trying to make a
point in the dismissal
i stole my friend's notebook in spanish
class when we were kids and he spelled
pants
like you would dance
like you're the dumbest [ __ ] kid
well a lot of us like could have is like
co usually off instead of could have
just apostrophe
you hear a lot of that stuff comedy is
one of those things that you can you can
do
for 10 15 20 years yeah and fool
yourself into thinking you have a job
because you're you're you're hanging at
the club you're out there you're around
other successful comments yeah yes and
you're working and you're right and you
and you had a great 15 minutes so you
did your work that day and and it feels
like you get away with that and then
dude you wake up did you wake up you're
40.
and then you got a gig in [ __ ]
indianapolis at the heel
17 taking or you can't sell tickets and
you don't have that that's what i'm
saying and then it dries up like [ __ ] i
said that to a couple of young comics
who were
less than young
if you're in your 30s and you're just
and i remember i just saw them and they
were just good guys and they were just i
know you're done yeah no you i remember
this you went up to him and go what are
you doing you're just hanging out mine
goes what are you doing they're just
like staring like that and they're
because they're around like you know her
and deleon like brian goes what are you
doing and they're all what no they go
we're kind of [ __ ] like we're going
to kind of [ __ ] boys yeah
what are you doing i don't know what are
you doing yeah the general oh we're
going to go to the laughing after brian
goes no i get that no what are you doing
in general
it's an important question it is a good
question hang around no one's ever asked
them that so they're like wait what they
didn't know what was going on they look
like they're looking those guys need
that they need it and i like them both
and i'm like yeah hey
you're bothering me with your general
energy all the time
with your whatever energy the lingers
the late
larry lingard get it together because
life is [ __ ] way shorter than you
think and you're gonna wake up and
you're gonna be way too old to make a
difference oh you hit him with a wet dab
in the face man that's funny though
if you did that to me and my friends
when you walked away i'd be like [ __ ] it
guys sucks
we're fine
is that like that the seller they're
lingers like guys like yeah they have a
very strict rule about like you can't
even sit you can't sit at the table
unless you're a comic yeah and then
everyone smiles somebody will sit down
no way and people are so impressed yeah
yeah yeah that's awkward which is also
awesome yeah you get crushed yeah
there's a there's literally a placard
that says like for comedians only yeah
and somebody somebody like bobby kelly
or
they'll just walk right up and just slam
it right in front of you while you're
sitting there
how's bobby doing i love him so much
he's so [ __ ] funny that's a guy like
if you think about the seller of like
dudes that'll
crush you if you've been bobby's killing
you so it's calling quinn yeah they do
they literally just sit there and if you
come in they're just lighting you up
they're on you yeah yeah and david tells
their all the time too yeah that tells
you dale's always like kind of tell's
always kind of like
moving around in and out smoking out
front yeah
he's wild
he's like me to me ins it's just
raw comic raw stand-up comfortable it
might be awesome number one you might be
all over
there
hotel's up there i mean his best show i
mean his best [ __ ] was
astonishing i was staying at the same
hotel as telling he's that like you know
like you are with athletes yeah time
with comics and i remember i saw him i
kind of panicked because we were both
outside i was waiting for my uber and
get a coffee and i looked at me as
cigarettes huh and then just jumped in
the uber
really yeah dude
i went cigarettes hunting and [ __ ] i
had the same exact story so i was at it
was at the cellar chris rocks at the
table it was me michelle wolf and chris
rock and i made chris rock laugh with
like a joke shitty like a sandy hook
joke or something where i was like
whatever i was like you know that didn't
happen right like it was just it was
something throw away and uh so i was
like made chris rock laugh i'm walking
outside i'm like dude this is it i'm at
the cellar then i walk outside and tell
smoking a cigarette i was like you got
an extra cigarette he just walked away
i was just like i am a [ __ ] idiot
stupid
what did i do
michelle wolfe is super sweet yeah she's
awesome she's really she came up with
you guys too right yeah yeah well no
they were the i'm three she was older
yeah she was she was like soda yeah yeah
yeah i never even she's a monster
she's awesome i saw her at the comedy
cellar i've never met her and she just
she goes oh hi she gave me a hug and a
kiss yeah so sweet i was like she's a
monster yeah do you remember she did the
white house address oh she's great yeah
yeah yeah yeah she's very funny
she's one of those like i was uh
you know when i was a
disgruntled open micro in philly it was
like women's socket comedy and then i
saw her kill oh god i'm wrong i opened
four it was like i wasn't even on the
[ __ ] show yeah she went up there and
just [ __ ] super talented mm-hmm
pretty much alrighty
thank you
appreciate it how's your neck
it's kind of the same
just never getting better not getting
better we're staring at the sun and
tweaked his neck no
something happened
i can't be the wrestling because it
happened like a week later two weeks
later that's
that wrestling helped it they put me on
another thing i had like a video visit
with a doctor or a nurse and then you'll
visit because i i'm trying everything to
get to get a freaking mri but then what
i could do is do a video visit so then
she go she put me on some sort of
quarter quote steroid did it help i'm
just it's a six day process so i'm on
the second day right now so hopefully
it'll get better so the reason he [ __ ]
his neck up is we call these two the
short kings and we
we had a thing where uh brian chappelle
played bouncers to see if they kicked me
out of the bar and the studios the bar
so neither one of these two could kick
me out i wasn't no it was brian chen oh
that's right so brian and chen tried to
kick me out obviously didn't happen yeah
and then uh we wanted to see if the
short kings could kick out chen
and apparently chin [ __ ] up probably
worn the same shirt too
it's pretty funny yeah this was actually
[Music]
[Music]
they're very strong splitting the double
team
wedge breaker chin look at chin
chin's not letting him get in he's two
giant guys
mark has the biggest wedgie in the world
see they broke the light
you didn't know it was going to happen
well that was pretty much it when you
when you feel that double team just drop
just drop straight down
wait we got taken away oh yeah they got
me out oh they [ __ ] really yeah
the short kings got me out
is that like a football thing yeah the
drop a little bit
yeah yeah oh right there
yeah they got me out pretty [ __ ] one
of the short kings needs to get to the
next level now watch this they do
right here look at kyle
look at this just get loaded
because he you picked his leg up well
done what yeah once you got my leg up i
was like oh i have no
short kings in the house yeah so [ __ ]
christian how was the tommy store last
night it was
it was good
the line not hesitate the lineup could
have been better but it was it was good
eric griffin ari
yeah uh the sky with the scalar twins
laura bros and then uh jesus trevor and
then like a bunch of people i didn't
even recognize it right uh i don't think
i saved hers i think i did before though
this so this kid george um he's never
been on a plane his dad was a heroin ag
addict he's in a wheelchair i think mom
passed away brother passed away from
overdosing okay this kid was a job yeah
yeah [ __ ]
no he's like peanut butter anyways uh so
he uh he lost he was sure he was 420
pounds he's down to 260. all right so we
flew him out yesterday he's never been
on plane flew him out had him on the
show
um then he wrestled stevie and stevie
beat the show whatever but uh he's in a
wheelchair uh his dad is oh so he takes
care of his dad wow and uh he was just
he was stevie blue eyes no no stevie
bobby people found my instagram you had
him wrestle someone they wanted to
wrestle he he put a singlet on steve you
put a
and they wanted to wrestle because
that's why he was losing the weight
motivation
he's like i'll beat the [ __ ] off stevie
rock all right prove it so then uh he
came out here and uh he [ __ ] he got
dealt with with stevie damn derek
brunson derek brunson yeah he's on food
truck so let's go back oh wait what the
hell it's probably yeah that's right
past 24 hours already passed
i still have a video tonight
it's all right but yeah that kid he's
down to 260 was 400 pounds never been on
plane you know has a [ __ ] job
you just feel for the kid he's like
how's it going you're making money he's
like i make 17 an hour dude i'm balling
that's crazy he's not bad where's he
from for america he's from chicago oh
chicago it's pretty good money but uh he
went to he's never been to the comedy
store he like looks up to the comedy
store so i called emily got him tickets
front row right boom store no there
wasn't a booth it was like the table
right there and uh the table is right on
the stage we were the first table rob
inside that yeah awesome so he's never
been and then
he i'm flying him from chicago to san
antonio my show's next week oh hell yeah
yeah so be with us in the green room oh
[ __ ] yeah it's amazing that's exciting
yeah that's super nice kid yeah really
good kid yeah is george harris super the
super sweet kid and he credits brendan
for changing his life he literally said
he changed his life yeah i told him to
lose weight and all that stuff yeah
what else oh that's awesome though yeah
all right so it's like a real [ __ ]
downer
that sounds terrible
is it in the
[Laughter]
a little sad
all right friend of the show jim brewer
i guess he's canceling a few of his
shows you see you announced this on
facebook live he's going because yeah
because the venues are requiring people
to have you know passports yeah
jim jim's going through jim's uh wife
and he's talked about this has cancer
right so and
he used the word terminal uh i hope
she's doing well i think she is and i
love jim favorite guest we've ever had
he's so [ __ ] great i mean i love you
shane and i jim was a great [ __ ]
guest
this is my favorite part
we're just saying bro but he uh i think
that he takes it like for him it's like
i i i think his kids had an issue with
the vaccine though something's going on
with his daughter she had an issue when
she got vaccinated oh and he just was my
thing
listen if this is his decision it's the
same decision as
a homeboy uh what's the guy ratatouille
uh
pat pat oswald
is that not a big movie i got kids no
everybody got it yeah you got it
same thing like
he canceled he was the main voice of red
to a huge movie for a kid yeah if you
don't know what pixar's dropping but
yeah he's great i love patton but uh so
he canceled shows in texas and florida
because they weren't requiring vaccine
stuff so he's so liberal but it's it but
that's fine that's his choice so but for
jim brewer like that's fine yeah like if
this is how you feel
and it's your show it's like it but but
again that's your thing yep isn't there
a huge theory behind patton oswald
killing his wife no not a goddess
no no
no no
don't float that [ __ ] out she passed
away from connection she also solved the
golden
no i think she died of a heart attack i
think she was taking bring that [ __ ] up
chin i i just heard it
conspiracy theory over there oh
let's find out dude i think it was pills
yeah it was
yeah medication yeah undiagnosed
recognition oh wow she'd take she was
taking she was writing and trying to
solve that case so she solved it she
solved the goal engagement yeah they're
going to be taking uh
stuff to stay awake in it looking to
find the kids right
it's very sad didn't he uh
god damn it i hate that stuff
talking about ratatouille bro
yeah those things take on our life we
love you meatball no no one believes
that he no that's not even a rumor but
you don't have a podcast called
conspiracy social club and i've talked
to a lot of people dude but that's not
that's not even a rumor like i've heard
rumors that's not even a rumor out of
patton oswalt i've had a number of
conspiracy like big time conspiracy say
that in that show and no i just well
there's something like you started
asking you start asking them where they
got their theories from
and yeah but that's not what he's doing
he was just you know it's probably yeah
he was just curious he probably got done
with a [ __ ]
kickball game and the boys were like man
how about pat and kill him you know like
that's other shits
he's a buddy so i i just bought him for
twenty bucks
right here yeah but we figured it out
see yeah see how we solved it case
closed let's see case closed he's not
gonna say it
it's pending he's not going to say the
case was really open
no i've never heard that my life it's
official
that's the problem let's clear this up
the problem is like what you were doing
before i was like well i mean i don't
know you know when you once you do that
you never know look into it
no not with patton like we know that
like we know pat he's a good good dude
yeah but
all right moving on michael shea is
getting sued i guess he has a sketch
show now and then one of the one of the
things he said or one thing one of the
sketches was something called homegirl
and then the homegirl homegirl hotline
where you can call this girl to take
care of all your issues because you know
when you're in an uncomfortable
situation with other girls this girl
will come in and take care of it
and it's not popping up now for some
reason hold on and uh so he had a skit
show sketchy sketch sketch show what's
it on hold on so here's the hbo yeah
here we go we have the sketch show
everything's on saturday live yeah
shane gillis good
it's good now i'm going to talk foreign
yeah he's a funny dude but he's getting
sued now because another girl says that
she did this before him and they're
taking her idea so i'll just play this
for you first homegirl this stuff's
tricky because he has rides
like it's like the amazing residence
with you now no okay but his belongings
are yeah great and can i get a vehicle
description and location his truck is at
work it's a black ford f150 i can give
you the address okay i am dispatching a
homegirl right now i need to leave the
front door unlocked for her you can feel
free to go back to bed and then we will
call you when we are finished
thank you homegirl hotline you did the
right thing by calling us all right bye
i gotta throw the music off on this
but this girl comes out i can i can
promise you i know
i know him parallel thinking there is
zero chance michael che saw this and was
like
i'm gonna do that yeah
it's like this isn't that original the
idea in the comic con level he knows
let's say he did do that he hey he
wouldn't get to the level he's at by
stealing stupid [ __ ] like this no yeah
and he's one of he's a really good comic
yeah like in very original
anyway yeah yeah i'll show you his part
or his one of his sketches for homegirl
your freaking son stole my freaking
thumb his thumb has it right there
where it's in his diaper my son ain't no
damn feet
well his sketch is way better yeah i got
this
oh what
i'm really sorry about everything
thanks home girl
oh come on
what
is the only thing
that's the only thing
that girl on tick tock doing this now
we're aware of it right yeah that's it
she's not going to win she's not going
to escape but also the only reason they
used homegirl on chez show is because
they couldn't say lesbian that's the
joke
the joke is you want to call a lesbian
to beat up a lady
that's the joke yeah
but they couldn't do that well it's very
interesting
how do you call it very different than
that this is way better yeah say so yes
because you're dealing with a real comic
but she's getting pr out of it now yeah
so she's more popular now it's going to
work what will happen is she's not going
to win no she'll the judge would watch
this like oh well he should just keep
doing it because it's funny in your sock
[Laughter]
have you guys seen this video no it's a
woman getting kicked down an escalator
in brooklyn and apparently she said that
she felt like her skin was being like
ripped apart because escalators have
those jagged little metal pieces
i don't know
it sucks they got to change it very
dangerous now these are your people
shane so
you said yours your hometown man yeah so
this dude apparently the guy was walking
up the escalator and and went by the
girl fast so she was like say excuse me
or something like that and then he just
kicks her yeah this guy was committed to
florida's state oh god hold up
you can see it here
he's passing by her he's like what
what the [ __ ]
straight up spartan kick yeah jesus
christ and just oh she ate [ __ ] oh yes
yeah i mean those escalators are crazy
what happened
they're still trying to find out well
she's all right but she has like a bunch
of lacerations straight up spartan yeah
what
yeah that's what sucks i feel like mass
[ __ ] things up because look at that
okay that's all i can get okay yeah yeah
that's every day okay yeah long hair
mask i'll find him with his eyes they
can find him nah it's me tough he has a
very unique hairstyle that maybe they
can get him
well one of somebody's going to rat at
him yeah oh yeah one of those things
what do you do like see how somebody in
here like say meatball did that after
spraying that horrible live button and
he kicked a girl down like we could tell
right away yeah like people that know
that kid are going to know right away
was that a nike backpack you know what
i'm saying
go find somebody dude that's literally
everybody in new york
that guy's he's going to be tough it's a
common look guy's a piece of [ __ ] is
what he is daddy [ __ ] spartan kick
that guy yeah
a girl to you oh god my [ __ ] you up dude
don't fight him on an escalator
he just want to know yeah
he's undefeated right now
um violence well just watch your video
you don't like that i want to hurt that
dude so badly that he has trouble
walking for the rest of his life okay
brian ugly so
dude move to new york and fight crime
finally i'm going to hurt that guy
either defund the police go [ __ ]
these two uh friends that are cops from
miami or they were former cops now they
did uh
their favorite thing was that bad boys
movie and you could check these guys out
too we all love that movie but they
actually look like they could be in a
movie
they're kind of like cops these are
actual cops in the left these guys are
fantastic
but oh man they got two indicators yeah
they're miami yeah
that's how you steal it
these are not good
bad boys for life
they actually put that in their thing
hell yeah
these guys are [ __ ] awesome so what
happened they're running drugs so they
uh they got tricked by the dea uh they
went undercover they got tricked they
got tricked because they wanted to help
you know god yeah they wanted help like
uh getting cocaine from one place to
another so they're going to like go in
the car with them and just be their
bodyguards right they want to make
because they wanted to be like it like
the movies
they want to make real yeah
but that was an inside sting so they're
now
yeah it wasn't real coke they're going
away for a long time for three years i
think and they lost their jobs for sure
they're lost being up being police
officers but another thing that sucks is
this guy on the right i think his name
is flowers his whole family's cops his
dad his sister oh yeah lineage
embarrassing
dude that's so embarrassing
it also sucks he's in that range route
can you imagine you got to go home to
them you got to go home now that does
not look like he's
dead don't look like he [ __ ] around oh
dude and dad's got to go back to his
precinct yeah but does he come does he
come home he's like dad come on man you
know what you know how much i love bad
boys
brother beat his ass like come on you
saw will smith dude that's the other cop
too
they're just living the life can you
imagine being that that age and did he
post this on instagram on his facebook
these guys are fantastic yeah what did
they say
what did they think was gonna happen
what did they think i also don't trust a
cop who looks that good and dresses that
way and also has all that money in a
strip club
is this justin elliot as a guy
there's a thing of cops doing like tick
tocks and [ __ ]
yeah that's not good did you ever see
one that came out that's not good that's
not good cops filming themselves in
their car like yeah dude be a cop the
only funny cop was the cop
lebron
which one said that he got fired but
then the gofundme saved him you never
saw it no so he uh you can't look it up
jim kelly cop he's making fun of
lebron was mad that that that cop shot
the black girl who's going to stab the
other black girl yes so uh lebron put
out like you know like your time's up
and like blasted i remember that yeah
this cop made a hilarious [ __ ] video
of it well
yeah
bellevue let go today after the office
said he was placed on a quote last
chance agreement with though because of
clearly laid out it's just a news
article
i'm sure the real video is out there
right
he's an idaho cop yeah you didn't see
this
no
but again so exactly why are cops doing
this
this one was actually [ __ ] funny dude
like he lost his job but [ __ ] it was
funny
my favorite part is when he goes michael
jordan's better he goes what nothing
have a good day
ryan let me go on youtube
i mean
oh are you on google no just yeah yeah
there's troops making tick tocks
it's awkward it's weird
when they when they dance is the worst
part
oh they do the dances they'll do but i
did like when the cops got into the
crate challenge do you see that cop yeah
that's a hoodie he's like what's up
everybody everyone's rooting against him
and he like falls and breaks his arm oh
no
he's all what's up kids stay in school
and then he's all like climbing up their
program
and he's like
flying up
dispatch everybody there it is
disturbance we have lebron call my cell
phone right away please thank you excuse
me sir excuse me no can you put the
knife down please sir sir no no no sir
don't stab it no no stop stab stop hold
on hold on it's lebron
lebron hey yeah it's me again listen i'm
out here at this disturbance call and
there's a guy trying to stab another guy
with a knife what do you think i should
do why does that matter
okay uh well they're both black
one guy's trying to stab another guy
with a knife deadly force is completely
justified uh-huh
i see
so you don't care if a black person
kills another black person but you do
care if a white cop kills a black person
yeah yeah
you're gonna get some [ __ ]
i mean it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense but then again you are really good
at basketball so i guess i'll take your
work
all right yep okay he needed an editor
here
michael jordan's the goat what nothing i
got to go
guys you're on your own good luck
i could have just left it if i could
have edited that i would have said don't
do the black white thing just do the
thing and get advice from him that's all
and it would have been funny yeah he
lost his job
uh this i just thought was cool he's one
of the best
what do you call those things
and there's one of the dallas texas all
right he should get a parkour
can't put the maze but he's not keto
definitely not keto but he is good at
his job
wow i love people that are good at their
jobs like this yep
so
someone says which way is the store
i agree
well get out of here dude yeah
oh here he goes
all right
he's actually really athletic amazing
actually
that's why look at this that is super
athletic oh [ __ ] like a b-boy yeah he's
actually athletic he just
look at that he just likes trees
he likes all the snacks he likes sweetie
he likes snacks there you go
wow
the passion
yeah a lot of passion super cuts and
then this guy one more time
oh the [ __ ] yes that guy that jumps
and doesn't look real oh that brian's
obsessed with yeah it's time to slam now
look at this
it doesn't look real
yeah but this is on a hard surface now
so you can actually tell
he almost hits his head on the yeah yeah
that's wild that is wow
but what's you know
what's he doing
flips at la fitness i know
maybe start spinning a sign for great
clips or something [ __ ]
yeah that's how you do it
okay so i guess this is a pretty popular
youtuber and then she wanted to do a
thumbnail with her son because i guess
something happened to their dog like it
died or something okay so she wanted to
do a thumbnail of them crying and i
guess she put that video out didn't
realize it she didn't edit it no
i'll show you this video right now
can't wait for her
to bring her home
and be part of our family
[Music]
and he's really crying about the dog
i am crying
oh boy
well she's she's pretty this is [ __ ]
hey let's give her a pass
shane let's give her a pass she's
smoking it's just a little embarrassing
i get embarrassed [ __ ] cringe keep
watching it gets worse
[Music]
oh
look at me look at me look at me
look at me look at me
i know look at me look at me he's
obama's
embarrassing
oh i hate i hate this i hate it look at
this oh my that's so irritating dude
cancel her right now
that is not hot anymore
oh okay i got it wow she's wild
so what happened to her they delete she
deleted it of course because you got a
lot of [ __ ] try to pay our bills what
was the what were they sad about did you
see the dog went missing or died
something like that
that's pretty fun yeah oh no new puppy
is sick
they're puppies sick yeah oh god that's
even worse
but i mean just the way she did it with
her son that son's not learning crap
[ __ ] horrible that kid's like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with mom yeah it's
just that's so heartbreaking because
like i'm actually crying
and i guess this would be the last one
rick ross never had his driver's license
so he finally got at age 45. all right
hey here's a bunch of cars over 100 cars
and he just gave his son for his 16th
birthday at buffalo wild wings
okay imagine dude working on buffalo
wild wings
you're fortunate oh no he's the wing
stop
a 16 year old comes in and say i'm the
new boss my dad bought me the store
and that's your boss wow and make sure
we fry those wings huh bud
you know
rick's really he turned it around a
little
he was like very fat he lost a lot of
weight yeah still he's still got a
driver's license yeah yeah but he was
huge yeah that's true
all right he's huge he's doing well he
he went on a diet yeah yeah he caught it
ross fit instead of crosstalk oh it's
really good oh wow yeah he lost got out
wow i like it when he's fat yeah he's
got an abe lincoln tattoo that's sick
where he does is ave lincoln and george
washington
and the statue of liberty dude this
guy's a [ __ ] patriot
i'm a fan is that it that's it
we love you you guys watch us go watch
your special on youtube right now i've
been the best you'll see all year he's
got tour dates as christy d said uh
it's brilliant it is brilliant look at
that picture
[Laughter]
are you gonna be shane uh
lafayette this weekend then austin for
like a week then phoenix arizona
and then milwaukee
so yeah check it out cool i'll be in uh
i'll be in um where am i gonna be
buffalo no denver comedy comedy works
september 23rd 24th 25th get your
vaccination or at least get a covet test
apparently chicago illinois the improv
schomburg improv i'll see you september
30th october 1 2 and then columbus ohio
funny bone october 8th and 9th
uh the next
friday and saturday i'm at the bud light
event center in san antonio texas i got
some dogs with me i got david lucas
chappelle lacey derrick poston the whole
crew will be there we have special merch
just for those san antonio shows special
think boy spurs inspired merch one show
friday one show saturday bud light event
center get your tickets right [ __ ]
now texas denver colorado september 30th
through october 2nd that's at the comedy
works downtown mama i got tickets for
you keep asking i keep telling you i
have them for you las vegas nevada wise
guys new club right outside las vegas
october 7th through the 9th then brea
california is october 15th and october
17th dallas november 11th and 13th all
right tickets at fatkz.com dallas where
are you at backflip all right october
7th through the 9th i'll be in tampa
florida at side splitters and then
october 28th through the 30th i'll be in
washington dc at the dc comedy loft boom
shane we love you dude
amazing
man thank you all right we're out